Good morning everybody!
I am... I'm still waking up.
Oh my gosh.
I need 12.30 to stream.
I can't believe I used to stream at 12pm.
Like what the fuck was wrong with me?
I could barely be awake at 12.30.
I remember when I used to stream at 12pm and then I was like, I can't guys.
My body is not strong enough for this.
Not ignoring my mind.
And that was like 12.30.
I was like, what?
Oh my god.
Who would have thought 30 minutes does no difference at all.
My body is still so weak.
Good morning everybody.
I'm so excited to play part 2 of Sandland!
I wanna do like, before we start, I wanna do a huge shoutout to Bandai.
For also giving us, I believe, 6 codes for Sandland.
2 for PC, 2 for Playstation, and 2 for Xbox.
So, if you somehow got the playstation, and you don't have a playstation, well, uh, that, well...
Actually, you couldn't because you have to activate that code on your playstation!
So, at the end of the stream, I would highly, I would be giving out these codes at the end of the stream.
So what I'll be doing is that I'll just be pasting the codes.
I'll just give a countdown for all you guys.
And I'd be like, pasting the codes in chat at the end of the stream.
And it just says playstation codes and xbox codes.
So I assume that like, it works on either.
I assume, okay?
So like, all you have to do, cause like, playstation 5 has like, uh, what's the word called?
It has like, uh, backwards compatibility for playstation 4.
So like, all you have to do is just, um, at the end of the stream, just have your playstation, playstation or xbox out in advance.
So like, you can like, fight for the code.
It's basically whoever puts the code down the fastest, um, would basically activate it.
So, so all you have to do is just have your fucking playstation xbox ready to activate the code on your console.
So, uh, and it's just whoever activates it first gets the game.
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, but yes!
Uh, so it'll be two PC codes, two playstation codes, and two xbox codes.
Uh, again, like a huge shoutout for Bandai for giving us these codes.
As well as the collectors, uh, sending me a collector's edition of the game.
I really honestly did not expect it.
I don't know if you guys know this, but like, Bandai was like one of the games I couldn't really play back then.
Uh, because, you know, perms.
So, I was like, super surprised.
Not gonna lie, I was so surprised with how supportive they've been, uh, with Sandland.
And how supportive they've been of me, like, playing, like, a lot of their other games.
Because I've always wanted to play, like, Digimon games.
Um, before then, but I couldn't.
So, like, it's really, really, I'm really thankful for Bandai.
Uh, to like, you know.
Supporting me, be like, encouraging me to play more Bandai games as well.
So, yeah, thank you again.
I really appreciate it.
Because, like, that means I can finally play, like, Digimon World.
Like...
I've always wanted to play...
I've always wanted to play Digimon World.
And I'm so happy.
I'll actually be able to, like, try it out in the future.
Uh, who's Doki's Digimon favorite?
My favorite has to be either...
Uh, Terriormon.
Uh...
Terriormon, Gabumon.
And also, uh, Renamon.
Uh, honestly, like, Gen 3 of Digimon...
What is it called?
Gen 3?
I don't remember.
It was Series 3.
Series 3 of Digimon is, like, the most optimal Digimon designs.
In my opinion.
Um, the only, like, Digimon designs...
Oh, Gatomon too.
I really love Gatomon as well.
Gatomon, uh, Terriormon, Renamon, uh, Gabumon...
And I think that's really it.
Um, but, like, I'm gonna say...
Gabumon fell down in my love for his design.
Because I've talked about this before.
But I realized...
Um, he's wearing a skinned animal.
I just... I realized.
Like, if you guys didn't notice.
He's not actually, like...
The fucking thing he has on top of him...
Is, like, his fur.
It's not even his fur.
And then you take it off.
It looks so ugly.
Like, people were like, What does it look like underneath?
And then I, like, looked up, like...
Like, they're, like, fan designs of what's underneath Gabumon.
And I'm...
And every time I looked at it, I...
It just ruined Gabumon for me.
I just... I just can't.
I can't take, like, Gabumon seriously.
Knowing, like, what it could look like underneath.
And it's just...
I'm sorry.
He's so ugly.
He's just...
I'm sorry.
Like, the...
The...
Without the pelt, he's so ugly.
And I can't...
Like, change my love for Gabumon.
Because all I can think about is what's underneath the pelt.
Well, okay.
You guys don't know?
Okay, here.
Here.
This is, like, what people think Gabumon looks like.
Because he has a double chin.
I don't know if you guys noticed.
But, like, the pelt hides the fact that he has, like, a double chin.
So, it looks so weird.
It looks so weird without the pelt.
Because then it's, like...
It, like, accentuates the double chin.
And I'm, like, oh...
Poor Gabumon.
Like, look at this.
Like, what the fuck is this?
Like, look.
There's a double chin.
What do you mean double?
Look.
It's right here.
Do you not see it?
I'm not crazy.
It's literally right here.
That's why he's so cute.
Okay.
Yeah, it's like a guy that shaves off his beard.
So, that's just a lie.
That's a fan design.
It doesn't count.
It won't hide the fact...
It won't hide his chin.
Like, his chin was the only thing that's exposed.
Anyway...
Anyway.
No matter what, we all know what's underneath is not as cute as what's, like, what he has.
Like...
But yeah, anyway, I used to really like Gobblemon.
And uh...
Joki is a didgy shamer.
Anyway, as I was saying, I used to really like Gobblemon.
But then my whole love for Gobblemon basically died.
He's still in my top 5 designs.
It's just that, you know, I realized he wasn't as cute as I thought he was.
Because all the cute factor comes from the thing he's wearing.
So...
So I was just like, oh...
I was just in love with the fur design.
I was in love with him.
And he died!
It's not even his fur!
That's the thing!
It's not even his fur.
So like, I'm not even in love with him.
It's like I was in love with what he was wearing.
So it's not really him.
He basically like skinned somebody else's fur and put it on top of him.
So whichever fur that came from...
That's the design I'm in love with.
You only liked him for his fur.
Damn right!
I'm not fucking ashamed of that!
I...
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe my Kamiyoshi exposing Gobblemon like that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah, I'm really thankful for Bandai for reaching out and...
And supporting this playthrough!
I don't know if you guys saw, but like...
You guys all know, this is actually the very last game that Toriyama was involved in.
So like, as I say, playing this game is sort of like a...
Like a lowkey tribute to him.
And everything.
But this was like the last game he was actually like...
Publicly involved in.
And they even like put up...
He even had like a statement written for this game.
Before he passed away.
I was like reading the statement and he was like really proud of this game.
And like really proud of like the world that was developed for this game.
Because there's like stuff that's not in the manga.
That like they added in.
And things that he wanted to be added to the manga.
That like they ended up adding in the game for.
So I'm really looking forward to playing more of Sand Land.
I'm really looking forward.
Anyway guys!
Let us start the game!
I played around the volume a little bit more.
Last... not last night.
Last playthrough before we ended the playthrough.
So I don't know if Sound Guy is here at the moment.
Uh yes.
You must return.
Do you wish to... yes.
Okay it's gonna be in Japanese now.
I hope you guys are happy.
You guys know the reason why I play in English is so that I don't have to read.
Like...
I won't be reading it out loud to you guys.
Okay?
All I'm saying is that you voted for Japanese.
So I will not be reading out the English dialogue.
Like...
Like you...
It's like subs versus dubs now.
Alright.
Continue.
Why?
Cause you guys voted for the Japanese dub!
What do you mean what...
Why not?
You guys had a choice!
Alright.
Let us go.
I... I never fucking remember how to play this game.
Alright.
How does she sound like?
Oh look.
It was a girl.
She's in garage.
Alright.
This is like...
Wait.
Do I have to upgrade my stuff again?
Did I upgrade anything?
I don't remember.
No!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna load game.
I'm pretty sure I saved it.
Right?
Load game.
A jump bot?
Wait.
Did I not?
Oh fuck.
I forgot to save it.
Okay.
Guys.
I forgot to save after upgrading my fucking tank.
Okay.
We got to...
Alright.
Did I upgrade my parts at least?
No I didn't!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
Alright.
I know we upgraded this.
Like I remember that.
Okay.
Alright.
Customized vehicle.
Uh...
How do I...
Okay.
Oh I can rename it!
Alright.
We're gonna rename our vehicle.
Uh...
How do I go...
What the fuck?
How do I...
I have to rename it on my...
Oh I have to rename it here.
Dragoons 1.
That means there might be a Dragoons 2.
The possibility that there's a Dragoon 2.
Alright.
Let's see.
Can I upgrade...
Uh...
Vehicle.
Upgrade vehicle.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm gonna upgrade the vehicle.
Try to see soon.
Alright.
Vehicle level.
Oh I can go all the way.
Let's go.
Whoa!
I have so...
Okay.
I don't have anymore.
I was gonna say...
Whoa!
I have so much stuff!
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I didn't realize that...
That has...
I have like...
To upgrade these parts as well.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh wait.
Customize vehicle.
Chip slot.
What did I want?
Power?
It was power, right?
Yeah.
Power chip.
Okay.
Here we go.
Uh...
Upgrade.
Okay.
I upgraded all of these.
Upgrade part.
Upgrade vehicle.
Uh...
Can these be upgraded?
Choose a part.
Okay.
Wait.
What?
Upgrading the wrong thing?
No.
I didn't.
Okay.
I did not.
I just...
Oh shit.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
No.
I didn't.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
I did not upgrade the wrong part.
I just have to be sure.
I just...
Reload time.
Attack interval.
I feel like...
Doesn't...
They both are very similar.
Okay.
Let's see here.
Uh...
Upgrade.
There you go.
Okay.
I've already upgraded that.
Alright.
Nice.
We're good.
Select vehicle?
Oh yeah!
I should have a jumper right now.
Right?
Where's my jumper?
No.
I don't.
Dragoon 2 would be the jump...
The jump one.
The jump tank.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's see.
I gotta talk to this guy now.
Alright.
And then...
Can I save here?
Save data.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh my god.
I...
I never saved.
I just...
I just relied on auto save.
Alright.
Uh...
Fill in.
Think of a 10 gift of ships.
Thank you.
A request?
He wants me to do shit again?
Machine gun scrapped is what I need.
Oh.
I'm gonna need a machine gun.
Ah, a shooting target!
Oh my god!
What?
Did that work?
Oh.
So it worked.
No, that didn't work.
What?
That was oh my... What the...
Where's my...
These things don't feel right.
You know what I mean?
This is the best part of time... Your windows aren't any better.
projet.
At least uh...
They're running a bounty on me at the moment.
But it's okay if they housed me, I guess.
We don't want to bring ourselves attention to the army.
But anyway, feel free to live in this place.
Oh my god, money!
I love doing things for money.
That's my job!
Alright, let's see.
We wanna...
Oh hey, they fixed it!
I just realized.
Okay, max the master volume.
Okay.
Got you.
I like how they fixed the...
I don't know if you guys remember, but we had an issue on launch where everything was just...
...flickering.
So, you know, it's good that they fixed that!
They actually fixed it!
Give the machine... Oh, I already did it!
Oh.
Did I do it already?
Obtain some machine gun...
Mayor, I did it!
I'll fix it!
I was fixing my settings!
But I did your job, Mayor!
It was so easy.
Yay!
Red Hammer, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay.
Okay, he has everything he needs.
Oh, I get to keep it?
Nice.
I got to keep the rest.
Isn't that great?
I did it, guys!
All I did was look at my menu and I completed my job!
I wish things were that easy.
Ha ha ha!
I'm still not sure if you'll have to stay.
What?
The town of Spino is a sinking ship.
I've been a butterfly for a long time.
It's a sinking ship?
What do you mean by that?
I thought this was like a utopia.
Young people like you haven't dated...
That butterfly...
Don't say things like you've given up...
If we all work together...
There's still...
What?
What's going on?
No!
How can it fail?
It has a population of like five people.
I don't understand!
No!
Seriously?
We can't repair the tank!
I'm sorry to walk and travel.
No!
We'll just deconstruct the garage and reconstruct it later!
There's only like two kids in this town.
For an old friend's son and wife to look after them.
I'm sorry I didn't ask you.
I didn't want to be a burden to you when you left the town.
I know.
I didn't want to leave as long as you were here.
But isn't that the same for you and Purika?
Wait, who's you and Purika?
Is that the kids?
I'm sorry, I forgot the names.
Oh, so it's like...
Just tell them...
Tell them like...
Grandpa hates them.
Then they'll understand.
It's a lie, but it will be a good lie.
You want the kids to die in this town?
That's so fucked up, lady!
Oh shit.
I like how these guys are just listening in to this very private conversation.
Hahaha!
I... I... I...
I like how they're just listening in and just standing there and being...
listening to this family drama like some fucking television show.
Then you should take me from some town.
This town used to be the base of the rebel army.
Now it's a place where the people from the country...
Oh, so they don't have food or water.
That's why this town is dying.
To be fair, there's like no young people in this town except for that one lady.
There's not many people who will move here.
Good listeners.
Well, then I guess I have no choice.
Hmm...
Do you know the princess?
She's been telling us about the good things of the town.
Does it help?
It doesn't even help.
It's just an ear.
Nobody moves in.
I'm going to make you feel better.
But they're like, oh, we want to attract more people to spin you.
But it doesn't help.
There's no new people coming in.
That's the whole problem.
They're not doing anything.
There's no new people.
Even if they're like, oh, this town is amazing.
We don't have food or water.
No matter how you gas up this town, it doesn't work.
Because there's no fucking food or water.
Let's tough it out just a little longer, Mare.
This is fucked up logic.
That doesn't solve the food problem.
Yes?
Hmm.
Oh my god, we're gonna help!
We're gonna do our job!
Alright, nice.
The demon king shall help.
Because that's what we know about the demons.
They love helping people.
Oh, the jump butt!
Oh, so how's the sound sound guy?
Yes!
They don't know who we really are?
I don't know, man.
A pink boy... is a very like...
Is a very like specific description, sir.
We're looking for a boy that's fucking pink.
Don't be scared of the demon.
But, prince... I'll keep looking for Izumi.
I can't just leave like this.
I'll help you.
I'll tell you what, I won't leave until I see Izumi with my own eyes.
Alright.
If you don't like it that much, you can leave.
No way...
If I leave the prince, what will people say?
Don't be like, you fucking failed, old man.
I hope you guys are like reading in time with the exact same time as me.
And I'm not going too fast.
I don't know how I'm reading is fast and is like too fast or not.
If you complete the Jump Mecha, you'll find Izumi.
I'm not reading.
What a girl with a kimono.
Let's see what... whoa.
Oh, we're back here.
I'm glad you left the Jump Mecha to me.
Alright, she's working on the jump battle on her own.
Oh, that's right.
She's kept me company for the entire time you helped me.
Oh, she's right.
The Jump Mecha.
Is it your用語?
Yes.
That's right.
I'm using the Jump Mecha.
Let's try to use it as a reference for our next show.
All right.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, no no no no no.
You, you came back?
Yes.
So, you're the first person who comes back?
I'm not.
This is...
old!
Wait, we fucking saw this before!
Wait, did they let me like, I fucking eavesdrop before?
Wait, this is the same!
I didn't even realize we've seen this cutscene!
Did we not?
Did we?
Okay, I saw this.
Sorry, we're skipping.
We saw this!
Wait a minute.
Alright, we're gonna skip.
We don't need a recap, guys.
It's gonna be like the Netflix, like, skip the intro.
I was like, wait a minute, I remember this.
It was him!
Alright, we see how it's different from like the original voice acting.
Not the English voice acting.
Previously on Sandland.
And...
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Guys, if you want... Oh my god, there it is.
I was like, where's the actual skip button?
Alright, here we go.
We can rewatch the scene.
Alright, bets on if I'll crash or not.
Guys, if you were like, Tokyo, why did you watch this scene?
Literally just play the last, like, five minutes of my vibe from the first playthrough.
But we only know how it sounds in English!
The Pitchers developed a machine that makes water.
The real devil is...
The real fiend here.
It's actually... me!
That's right, you're a fucking war criminal.
Live and die with your guilt.
Absorb.
Welcome to the Toriyama Cinematic Universe.
I'm gonna turn into a giant monkey now.
Alright, here we go.
This is where I crashed.
Maybe they patched it.
Maybe they patched it?
Oh, thank god.
.
I was like, oh please don't be the Doki Jinx.
And it actually crashed.
I half expected it to crash.
Not gonna lie.
I was like, oh no.
I might have jinxed it.
Alright, sound guy, up the volume again.
Let me know if it's better.
Then go to the suspense.
I know, I was like, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
Oh, oh!
Okay, sorry.
Now I remember...
Now I remember why we never saved.
It didn't crash, but at what cost?
It was a car.
That's not the jump bot.
Yeah, I was gonna say, you made a car?
.
You were just, I don't know.
You were going in the sand land.
People were fucking killed at that point.
It's literally anime Mad Max!
.
Of course.
Yay!
I got my car back!
Oh shit, I get to have my own car?
Say no more.
Say less.
Yeah, they stole my fucking dinosaur too.
I can't believe I got GTD'd.
Oh shit, you're right!
Where's our jump bot?
I really love the 3D models on these.
They look so... they look like... they really look 2D and 3D at the same time.
I know, right?
Wait, I'm not gonna lose my car.
You're gonna lose your car?
Yeah.
I'm not gonna lose my car.
You know what I'm just happy about?
I am so fucking happy that like for an anime adaptation of a game for like a game adapted from a anime slash manga That's not a fucking fighting game I am tired!
I am tired of game adaptation!
That's just a fighting game.
I don't care what anybody says.
I'm so fucking tired of it.
There's a whole world!
We need more anime fighting games.
Bro, that's basically like 90% of Dragon Ball Z games.
But at least it makes sense because it's Dragon Ball Z.
There's some fucking anime fighting games that don't fucking make sense at all.
Alright, let's see.
Let me push the overall volume a little bit more guys.
Sound guy requested!
Alright, I pushed it up.
Let me know if that's better.
...
Guys, I'm like this close to having like in like...
I'm putting it back in English.
...
I'm tired of reading already.
Okay, alright.
We've had...
We got our Japanese...
I'm sorry guys.
I'm just not as strong.
...
Reading is so hard.
I'm like reading and also trying to think at the same time.
...
I haven't done that since university.
I'm too tired to right now.
...
Finally I don't have to read!
Finally!
Gladstone don't!
Oh, a little bit too late there.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
...
Reading the game and reading the chat.
There's just too much reading going on.
My brain just can't.
...
It lasted 36 minutes.
I did... I don't think it was even 36.
Because there was like a time where we had to do other stuff.
Alright, here we go.
Back at...
We have to assemble the...
We have to go back and forth?
...
Yay!
We did it!
...
Now we have the jump bot!
Make the necessary parts.
I have money!
How do I do this?
Make a part.
You need money materials to make parts.
Select the vehicle type with LB and select part to make.
Choose and build.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Uh... We need this.
...
Okay, we got that.
And then we need to make this.
Nice.
I knew being a loot goblin was the way to go.
No!
I need a fucking scorpion oil and raptor steel?
I'm too lazy.
I'll fucking... I'll go with default.
I don't want to farm.
I'm too fucking lazy for that.
I think that's it, right?
I made it.
Did I make everything?
You should be made.
Did I not make you?
Oh, go to make vehicle.
Okay, vehicle.
Make vehicle.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Once you have what parts are required, go to make parts.
Okay, I did it.
Alright, nice.
So let's start to create...
Okay, create part four.
Once I set up slots...
Okay.
Nice.
I made you.
You can never leave...
when you live under this house.
Alright.
Assemble.
Dragoon.
Better dragoon.
Two.
There we go.
Why couldn't you be just like my better dragoon?
Dragoons.
Why couldn't you be just like...
I can't.
See you later.
Did I make it?
Dragoon.
I can't believe you really made it.
I did.
What you talking about?
You didn't think she could?
I'll be honest.
I had my doubts.
You must have had a fine mentor.
Alright, so I get how's the voices now.
No mentor for me.
I'm completely self-taught.
She watched those YouTube videos.
I can't think of what I could have here and there.
There's just always been a lot for me to tinker around with.
Incredible.
In any case, this should allow us to slip past the army and continue on our journey south.
Yeah!
We can jump now.
I don't know.
This does not look like sneaky.
When can I upgrade my fucking cheese?
I don't care.
What happened to the Japanese dub?
I got tired of reading.
It's too early in the morning for me.
What for?
We're at a scout?
I want to see what the army might be able to throw at us.
Oh, we're gonna test it out?
Okay.
Wait, is there more talking?
And we talk like every day.
What else do you want?
When can I customize my fucking...
Uh...
When can I customize my like fucking...
Like...
Wait, what do I want to customize?
Oh, my town!
Sorry, I lost my train of thought.
This is exactly why we have to put it back at English.
I actually lost my train of thought in the middle of thinking about it.
Yeah, her.
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, my God, that's creepy!
That smile!
She's a good girl.
Oh, hey, oh!
That smile, bro!
She was enjoying herself so much it was positively infectious.
Just watching her work put this car lover in a good mood.
Oh, car lover.
Next time, come over to say hello instead of staring at me.
No, no, Ed!
No!
You need a supervisor there if he's there alone with you.
You cannot be alone with this man!
Did you not see how he fucking smiled at you?
Cars are awesome.
Sure wish I had my own.
Ooh.
Stranger danger.
Stranger...
Oh, my God, what the fuck is wrong with that?
Then you should really head to the junk pit.
He needs a chaperone.
You need a body guide.
Junk pit?
Turn right at the fork leading to the Leesob Junkers Market.
There's a pit where junkers toss all the stuff in it.
He just really, really loves cars.
You don't understand.
You're saying I could find a car there?
I could get a car?
Maybe not a whole car, but you might find a freight.
You do not go to that mad junk pit.
I'll be sure to bring mine.
Okay, car park.
Oh, these are all like side quests.
I can't wait to not...
Oh!
Meowjin Boo!
Hey, nice to see you again.
Is it just my imagination or has the town gotten more lively?
Oh, yeah.
I found something cool.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the free stuff, Meowjin Boo.
Okay, do I have anything?
I need like two ancient coins?
Bring me any rare items you find.
Fucking greedy as hell.
What are you going to do with the ancient coin?
You want me to fucking...
You want me to fucking like ruin more ancient ruins?
That's why it's called ruin.
Sorry, I'm going to discover...
I'm here to discover more national treasures.
I...
I'd heard demons were attacking passersby.
Stealing water and such...
Water?
But there's so much water behind you.
Wait, I thought you guys were attacked like no food and water.
What is that behind you?
I...
I just got scared.
Well, there's some truth to that.
But it sounds like...
I'm just bringing you back to the museum.
You're right.
... rather inflated.
Attacking passersby?
We only take what we need from the royal army.
Exactly!
From the army?
You go up against armed soldiers?
Yeah, because apparently the army is more evil than fucking Satan himself.
You must be really strong then.
Sure am.
And I'm only nine.
No wonder you can travel the dangerous sand land unscathed.
That's bleach.
What the fuck?
I guess you're too strong to find it dangerous.
But to us humans...
stepping outside town isn't something you do lightly.
Just traveling across the very desert is good enough.
Those weak flesh bodies.
But with the risk of bandit and raptor attacks as well...
we're risking our lives every time we go to another town.
Hmm.
That bad?
It is.
I can't travel alone either.
Yeah, I can tell why.
Even seasoned peddlers have to go.
You're basically let a little boy do all the fighting for you.
I can see why you can't travel alone.
And you're a goner.
So you need luck just to reach your destination.
Wait, is this an escort mission?
I guess that means I was lucky to meet you guys.
Talking about all this has got me feeling a bit uneasy.
She looks like Chi Chi.
But with brown hair.
Well, I ordered some new wares from a merchant.
Oh my god.
Have you guys seen like...
Pecora's been like doing like the Dragon Ball Z streams and stuff.
And like I...
She's never fucking watched or played any Dragon Ball Z...
Like Dragon Ball games.
And it's actually...
Or read any Dragon Ball before.
So she like basically went in with zero knowledge of Dragon Ball.
And I was like, how?
Like I can see if you're like overseas.
But she lives in Japan.
How...
That's just insane.
That is just...
I was like, that's actually crazy.
Like growing up in Japan and never reading, watching or playing any Dragon Ball game.
That's...
I just like...
That blew my fucking mind when I heard.
He's always had incredible luck.
So I didn't think much of it.
But...
What if he's in trouble?
So it's actually like she actually goes in with zero knowledge.
And like reacting to it live for like first time seeing all these things.
So like a lot of drag...
Obviously like, you know, Dragon Ball is like a huge like cultural phenomenon like overseas and also domestically.
And so like people like are watching it because it's like you can see an actual first time live reaction of somebody.
Like never...
Who's never had any background information about Dragon Ball.
Like experiencing it for the first time.
So they're basically like reliving their life.
Like they're watching it so they can like...
What's the word called?
It's like Outer Wilds.
Like basically reliving the experience through her type deal.
Um...
Beelzebub.
If you ever see that merchant in trouble during your travels...
Could you please help him out?
Maybe if I'm in the mood.
Thank you.
I'm counting on you.
And they're living vicariously through her to re-experience Dragon Ball Z for like as if it's like the first time again.
Which is very rare.
It's actually...
Like it actually blew my fucking mind that she never had any like Dragon Ball knowledge before playing the game.
Because she doesn't know anything that's going on and she's like what?
Like what the fuck?
Alright.
It's time to go.
How far did I know the Dragon Ball arc?
Pretty far.
I've actually...
Like I watched...
I watched Dragon Ball from like...
Like the...
When he was a little kid.
To...
Uh...
To like...
I...
Was it GT?
I watched...
I didn't...
I didn't watch all of GT because it's GT.
I don't know much about...
I don't know much about like the...
The world saga.
Like the world tournament.
Not that the world tournament...
Who the fuck is this guy?
Oh it's...
Do I save him?
Oh I guess I'll save him.
No!
My fucking taxi!
What if I intimidate him?
Okay hello.
Hello.
Intimidate.
No!
Stop right away!
I can't believe it!
My daddo!
He ran away!
My car ran away!
Give me the fucking money.
Why do you have your eyes closed?
Well...
Because...
What was it?
The universe tournament.
The one where like...
Like the universe tournament.
Not the world tournament.
Yeah.
I stopped...
I haven't watched...
Dragon Ball Super?
Is it...
Is it Super?
The one with like...
That was like the sequel to Dragon Ball Z?
Because like we don't...
We don't talk about TT.
Sharko!
That's like living in America Canada.
I'm never playing Halo.
Oh wait that's me!
I never played Halo!
The multiverse tournament.
Yeah!
Like the only thing I know about Super is the...
The cat guy.
And then like the...
The tournament of power.
And I know about the tournament of power arc.
Because I watched a little bit of it.
Because I thought it was super interesting.
And uh...
And I watched like a little bit of the tournament of power arc.
And like read the Wikipedia.
Of like everything about the tournament of power.
Because I thought it was like a super interesting arc.
And then that's the only thing I know about Dragon Ball Super.
If it's not one thing it's another.
Another for this guy.
And here I thought that with the raptors gone...
I'd finally get to make my deliveries to Spino.
Oh you're a delivery man?
Spino?
Wait are you a peddler?
Yeah what are you?
Indeed I am.
Then hurry before you get attacked again.
Aedes is waiting.
Oh you know Aedes?
Yeah I know Aedes.
Are you the one who drove the...
Yeah that's me.
They were snapping at my heels so I sent them flying.
That's all.
Even so.
It doesn't change the fact that you saved me.
Here.
Take this as thanks.
I don't want it.
No!
What?
I do!
If I don't thank you properly...
What the fuck do you mean I want it?
Instead of don't want your thanks.
Don't force it on me.
Well then I'll follow your advice and hurry on to Spino.
Bye.
Give me a break.
What's wrong with that guy?
What the fuck he gave you something and you're like what the fuck is wrong with him?
He gave me free shit.
Like what's wrong with you?
Like Payton thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
From Fallout to Dragon Ball.
How the Doki supremacy continues.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
I can't.
God damn it Beezlebub.
We love free stuff.
I got like one experience for that.
That's actually crazy.
Guys I have to go back for my car.
Actually no I don't need it.
Let's try the jumper bot.
Let's see how that's like.
Where would the others get on?
Okay.
All pilot move.
Leave vehicle.
Boost.
X to stomp.
Shoot.
Hold to aim.
Reload.
Okay I'm gonna forget like majority of this.
So yell at me if I don't remember.
Wait where are the others?
Do they just not exist?
Oh my god look at me go.
I wish I have my Raptor.
Okay we gotta go.
East Valley.
Water supply point.
Gifted flowers.
Do I care enough about the people?
Okay wait.
This is a junk pit.
The diamonds boss.
Alright we gotta run.
Alright.
We're just gonna run.
Oh my god we're going 49 kilometers.
Kilometers per hour.
What's that supposed to mean?
What the fuck does that mean?
Okay I'm gonna.
What does this look like?
Okay that's what that does.
Okay and then...
The stomp move and alright reload.
Alright we got this.
Oh my god look at all these.
Oh my god, there's so many babies!
Oh my god, it's so easy to kill them!
Look at all these children!
Wait, they have to run behind me?
Okay, that's pretty funny.
Until there's only one left.
I like how the NPCs are just following behind me.
Alright, nice.
It's okay, there's still one more left.
What the fuck?!
The pterodactyls hate me as well?!
But why?!
I'm a good person!
What did I do?!
I basically...
Oh, I killed like...
Because they need the babies to eat.
Alright, let's make sure we kill these people.
Sorry, not kill.
Just injured them a little bit.
Because we don't kill, guys!
Remember!
Guys, I don't know if you guys remember this, but we don't kill in this universe because killing is a line we will never cross.
Let's see, we gotta get rid of him...
and him.
Alright, we did it.
Oh my god!
Simulate time!
This is mine now.
Oh shit.
We gotta shoot some birds down.
There can only be one bird in the sky.
Don't kill a child, murder it, pack it...
Wait, he gets his own car?!
Okay, I like how he follows me with his car.
Okay, that's nice.
That's pretty good.
I like that, actually.
He just follows me in his own car.
No one's safe from me.
Baby is easier to kill.
It's just stomping on some bugs, guys.
No big deal.
Did I kill him?
Wait, no I didn't!
No, I did!
Alright, don't worry.
Don't worry.
You're gonna be a widow now.
Actually, no.
Let's just have the kids be orphans.
Alright.
Nice.
The kids have more loot.
No, the moms have more loot.
So it makes more sense.
To just kill the mom.
The kids don't give as much.
See?
Look, the mom gave me like...
Venom and the exoskeleton.
Alright, we're gonna loot this.
Loot.
I'm just doing my part.
Exactly!
I'm doing my part.
We're playing hell...
Anime Helldivers 2.
Jacob, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
This game has everything.
Anime Mad Max.
Anime Helldivers.
Anime...
Wow.
Their defenses are much stronger than I expected.
Anime Mad Max.
Guma, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I like that you guys joined the tomato farm the moment I started killing kids.
Like, I don't know what that says about you as well.
It's practically a fortress.
There's no breaking through that.
As expected, we'll have to take a detour via East Valley.
We'll have to take a detour via East Valley.
Hmm.
What is this?
What's this?
Whoa!
Teria, Shiva!
Wowza!
That's my...
lucky charm.
Whoa, yeah?
How lucky.
Wait a minute.
Wait a second.
What do you do in this tank?
What did you do in this tank?
I used to be a famous movie star.
Sexy Terrier, right?
Sexy Terrier.
You might act like a stick in the mud, but looks like you're a dirty old man on the inside.
But looks like you're a dirty old man on the inside.
Shut up and sit down.
We're moving out.
Yeah, he's a dirty old man.
No, I can't say it.
I can't say it.
Planning to face the army, old man?
Is that what the lucky charm's for?
What?
But you said we weren't going to fight the royal army.
But the old man's obviously gotta pay the royals back.
For what they pulled on him.
Hold on.
Please tell me you're joking.
That was 30 years ago.
It's your fault, thief.
Wait, why was it his fault?
What did he do?
You're the one who blabbed all those secrets to him like a total know-it-all.
Wait, what?
How did you shift the blame?
He's literally just like the fucking third wheel.
But if the royal army gets in my way, I'll gladly take them on.
I'd give my left arm for a chance at Supreme Commander Zeyu.
Poor man.
He gets like fucking...
What?
Who the fuck is this guy?
He's just catching some strays.
Who's this guy?
Papa!
Oh my god, Papa!
That shit...
Bro, okay.
If he has a bod like that...
Yeah, I'm not surprised he's fucking not wearing anything.
Bro, he's gotta flex it, man.
If he hasn't, he's gotta show it.
How the fuck do I get there?
It's like here.
There's no fall damage anyway.
Oh my god!
Guys!
It'll be okay.
It's just a flesh wound.
See it?
Nothing bad happened.
Guys, nothing bad happened.
Oh my god!
You mean I wasn't supposed to fall down?
No!
I fell down for no reason?
Oh...
That seems like something I do.
There's... that's...
That's something I do.
Okay, wait.
Maybe I can salvage this guy's...
Guys, I can salvage this guy's...
It's parkour time.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
There has to be a way to cheese this.
Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew it.
If there's a way...
I will Skyrim this shit if I have to.
I knew they would...
Build a Skyrim for me.
I knew it.
It's like I didn't fuck up.
We actually did it!
Wooo!
I am determined.
Where's a horse when you need one?
If only you had a jump pot If only you had a jump pot that could jump.
No!
Okay, let's get the jump pot out.
Alright.
Now we need the jump pot.
There is a jump that I cannot make.
No!
Okay.
Guys, there's a delay when it comes to jumping.
Did you guys know that?
What the fuck am I...
Okay.
There's like a delay you don't understand.
Are you fucking...
I...
Bro!
No!
Game over!
Okay.
Guys!
There's a delay!
Like what the fuck!
Okay.
We're gonna try again.
There's a delay in jumping!
I swear to God!
Okay.
Like I can't stop the delay!
What?
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my God, I did it.
I fucking did it.
Guys, I beat hard mode.
Guys, this is the hardest part of the game.
This is... This is the hardest part of the game.
This is the hardest part of the video game chat.
You don't understand.
You don't understand how difficult that was for me.
We could reach it.
Okay.
Ooh, loot!
Nice.
Oh, thank God I have a robot that can jump.
Oh, now it fucking responds!
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
This is a cover up from the government.
The government doesn't want people to know how good I am at video games.
So they purposely added nurse for me.
Like...
It's not a conspiracy if it's true.
The government purposely added lag.
So I wouldn't...
So I wouldn't hit those jumps.
They added latency on my jumps.
I don't want my true power to show up.
I swear to the peeps, she's catching on.
Quick, somebody!
How's the volume so far?
Is it like loud enough?
Or too loud?
I just wanna be sure.
Bro, I'm so mad.
I'm gonna start killing the wildlife.
It's the leader of the raptors.
The leader?
This guy?
Bro, I can just shoot the raptors.
We have to be careful though.
Like, look, I can just do this.
You...
Oh shit!
See, look at that.
I can just do this.
Wait!
Wait, he can't fucking leave!
Wait, he's stuck!
Oh, he's not stuck, guys!
He's not stuck!
Oh, what the fuck!
Okay.
Okay, it's okay.
There's no way he's gonna kill me.
Wait, he has to!
He has fire?
I could jump.
I could jump from that.
What?!
Okay, one more hit.
One more hit.
Nice, we did it.
Let's see.
Oh, it just gives me like five raptor skills.
The air shot.
They want the true power of the silver unleashed upon them.
Breeze, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're hiding my true power.
My power level.
Chat.
It's the government.
That is a conspiracy I'm willing to get behind in.
Wait.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, now I don't have any repair kits.
This is gonna be a little bad.
Am I going the right way?
It's like here, right?
The East Valley?
Yeah, alright.
It's here.
We're gonna get rid of the scorpions.
Alright, we're gonna make more orphans.
Eventually, those orphans are gonna find the moms that I spared.
And then I'm gonna...
And then they're gonna thank me.
Alright, and then I'm gonna kill the kids here.
So then the mom can adopt the orphans that I made behind me.
And then there!
I solved the orphan problem.
And then they're gonna like love each other from the trauma they built together.
What's this?
They're gonna thank me for...
Thank me for saving them.
Wait, their family bond is gonna be stronger than blood.
Because I basically...
Oh, the sandfall.
I did a risky mission.
Give me the money.
Thank you.
I only do this for the money.
Wait, is that bad guy?
Oh, that's so pretty.
That's fu- It's not fucked up!
Because...
You don't have more...
It's only fucked up because you still have empathy.
Okay, wait.
Can I have him like shoot things for me?
It's called practicality.
Nice, let me...
So it's extra fucked up.
Okay, let's grab this.
I want the gems.
I like how I can farm these things without having to get off the...
get off the jumper bot.
Is there anything above me?
I feel like there's something above me.
That's even more fucked up.
Oh my god.
You sound like somebody that has moros.
Who still has that?
What's over here?
Is this like...
a secret area?
No, I don't know if I should go this way.
I'm not going this way.
They're children?
I thought moros got patched.
Oh my god, moros in 2024?
Morality?
This is why we got rid of the morality system.
It's actually true.
I don't know if you guys noticed this.
But like, I feel like more and more recent games, like games that used to have a morality system, they got rid of the morality system because they realized gamers don't care about...
Have you guys noticed that?
Like some games that used to have like morality system, they like patched it.
They got rid of it.
We go to any lengths.
We definitely need like repair kit, guys.
Okay, repair kit.
Oh wait, no.
I shouldn't sell it.
I want to buy a repair kit.
Okay, I'll buy two.
We might as well.
We have a lot of money, right?
Yeah, we have a lot.
Yeah, undertale.
Yeah, but do you remember...
Do you know how old undertale is?
A lot of like more...
recent AAA...
Well, I was gonna say AAA games, but a lot of like more recent video games have gotten rid of it.
GTA, who needs more?
Guys, I'm still okay.
Okay.
Wee.
How do I...
How do I miss that jump?
Oh my god, did my NPC die with me?
I hate this.
I actually hate this.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
This fucking sucks.
Okay.
I blame the government.
The government is adding latency to my game.
I swear to God!
It's not me!
There's a lag!
I swear!
There's like lag!
I doubt it'll be quite that simple.
Even so, it's a big step forward.
Well, what are we waiting for?
Let's get up there!
Okay, we gotta jump.
Okay, we also gotta heal.
Uh, we did it!
We healed!
Alright, here we go!
How do we get up there?
Do we jump?
Falling from here would barely even tickle.
Okay, we got this.
Look at that!
I figured it out!
See, look at- this is what my true power is like without the government trying to nerf me.
Look!
Oh, and then suddenly there's no latency between my jumps?
Like, what?
Coincidence?
I think not.
Don't fall out of the Doki platforms.
Come on, thief!
Tired already?
You need to get off your butt more than once every hundred years.
Easy for you to say from a jump bu- huh?
Huh?
Prince!
What?
Huh?
Whoa!
Shoot the rock!
Oh, jump?
Close!
Look, I just shot the rock.
It's a rock.
Papa!
Oh my-
Don't worry!
Just keep going!
I'm sorry, like, I like how the guy on the far left just doesn't have a fucking nose.
He just has two holes.
Like, what?
Huuuuuuuh.
Pike!
Sketch all their faces for me, would ya?
Coming riiight up!
The fuck is he- what?
What is he doing?
They have good team chemistry.
What a team.
Beelzebub!
Wait, do they know who I am?
Hey, man, that's your butt!
Beelzebub!
That's me!
Why is the fiend- How does he know who I am?
Then you're a human!
What are we doing?
Everyone just- Oh, I've beaten him up before.
Don't be a coward!
You know this guy waxes too, cause like there's literally no hair on his face.
On any of them.
My god.
Swimmers!
The biggest, baddest criminals in all of Sandland!
He waxes all the hair off, except for the mustache.
And be ready to run if it doesn't work!
Okey dokey!
Doki, please!
Look!
There's no hair anywhere!
It's the swimmers!
Hydrodynamic!
The swimmers?
As in the swimmers?
The famous bandits?
I should have known those crooks would play dirty!
Giggles, thank you for the superchat!
Your very first superchat too!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, I remember wishing you a happy birthday last time!
Just wanted to say thank you for making my birthday so special last Thursday.
Here's a little something to show my love and support.
Mwah!
I'm excited for everything you have in the future!
Thank you!
Thank you for the superchat!
The Jokebot's history is so much that a single boulder connects with it.
Oh!
Oh yeah, I remember asking how you guys think the sound was now.
But then I didn't look at chat.
Oh shit, it's 2D time!
Is the sound okay?
Wee-oo!
I can speedrun this.
Oh god, woah!
Oh, I don't know...
Oh!
What the fuck?
Where was the...
Where was the fucking...
Assist?
Oh, you guys said it was good?
Huh?
It's Donkey Kong time.
Time to beat him up.
Shoot him!
Oh yeah!
Wait, you're right.
It's because our bond grows stronger.
Oh, I have to go this way.
I have to go backwards.
Guys, guys, guys!
It's not a skill.
I swear it's not a...
Shoot it!
Shoot it, old man!
I feel like he's in the bathroom.
Like...
Oh my god, it sounds like they're in the fucking bathroom right now.
It's throwing me off.
It's actually throwing me off.
No weak knees, boys!
Let's go!
I thought someone was in my house.
It sounded like someone was in the bathroom.
The public bathroom.
Guys, I haven't used my fists in so long.
I've been using my...
Holy shitty uppercut in me!
Oh my god.
Bro, I haven't...
How do I dodge?
Oh, it's this.
Okay.
Guys, I haven't used my fists in so long.
I don't know what that is like.
Using my hands?
What's that?
Don't back down now!
What the fuck is using my hands like?
It's dark!
I made machines!
The machines have been doing all my work for so long!
What is this like?
Wait, can I combo him?
Can I combo him so he can't do anything?
No, I can't.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Wait, can I send in my...
God, okay, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have special skills.
Wait, give me a sec.
I have... Rush!
That's fucking right!
I remember how to dodge, guys.
Can't track him!
Guys, I can't see him!
Where is he?
Is he in front of me?
You despicable fiend!
Attacking poor, defenseless humans!
Cream on!
You're the ones who started this fight!
Oh yeah, I was like nut level.
How would you like me to finish it?
Guppy!
Guppy?
What are you calling Guppy?
Oh shit, what about gun?
That's not fair!
Dang it!
Wait, he just shot his leader?
Oh, it was like a smoke screen.
Oh, that's smart.
I mean, they could have shot him, but like, I guess that works too.
Hey!
Alright,
nice.
I did it.
I did it!
Of course, I'm literally bulletproof.
We've established this.
Wait, that's me!
That's me!
Oh my god, he's an artist.
He's so beautiful.
But what would they need this sketch for?
It's me!
Hire me, I'm cheaper.
Let me voice act in your game.
I'm pretty sure I'll be cheaper.
Because I'm not in.
Oh no, that's so fucked up for me to say.
Guys, this is a joke, but I was gonna say I'm not in the union, so I'm cheaper.
But that's a joke, guys.
I mean, I'm not in the union, but like, I wouldn't, you know, take a job for me.
You've got a gap of a drawing, son.
I feel like I've seen this guy somewhere before.
Nah.
Alright, shark.
Jesus, Cap, shake my hand.
Go sell this pic to the news office.
Don't let him have it for any less than two million zeni.
Milk, I'm dry.
You hear?
What the fuck is wrong with his nose?
He looks like...
What the fuck?
Holy shit, he doesn't need no nose.
I can level up.
Yay!
Yeah, he looks like fucking Voldemort.
Okay, I can level up.
Alright, let's see.
Uh, what do I want?
Enhance power, boost, realize power, raises power, darkness, follows, boost powers, a bee attacks.
Uh, boost...
Okay, I want boost...
Oh, I already did.
I already have boost power of X.
Uh...
Maybe...
Power of...
Bee?
Wait, did I learn this already?
Let's see.
Follow up...
I guess we'll try this.
And then...
So we can get...
Yeah, we can get the max HP.
We want that.
Alright, what do I want from him?
Extraction, deploy...
Disploy nearby his number of targets for spoils of war.
Dropping more items.
It's gifted with...
Oh, I want more items.
Okay, we're just gonna do a thief.
I feel like the thief has better...
You're not able to learn this skill.
I feel like the thief has better, like, abilities.
Passive wise.
It's all about the items.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, is this death?
Hey guys.
So don't...
So, uh...
Welcome back to my playthrough.
As you guys know, do not jump into the sand of death.
Do not...
Do not jump into the sand of death.
Please,
if I keep spamming...
Guys, I feel like I should have been using this.
I don't know.
Guys.
That's quicksand.
I don't know if you guys know this, but visually, that's quicksand.
So that's why there's a bridge.
Why did they build a bridge for sand?
Are they stupid?
Alright, let's see.
I wanna grab...
Oh, there's some materials down there.
Alright, let's grab that real fast.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Stealing time.
It's not stealing because it's mine.
I don't wanna get back up top.
Oh.
Oh, there's stairs here.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I was gonna say, did I fuck up?
There's stairs here.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab the jewels.
The gems.
Not the reload!
Okay, reloading.
Just give me infinite ammo.
I need a reload.
Red Dog, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay,
we're gonna make sure...
We're gonna make sure we reload this too.
Is this it?
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Wait, how do I get there?
Wait, what?
What?
How do I get there?
I'm so... what?
Is this... is there a way downstairs?
Or is that dead end?
Me!
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh!
There was a hole.
Down is up, guys.
Oh shit!
Sorry, I keep forgetting there's no fault.
It's not this?
Oh, do I have to use like the no- tank?
Do I have to use the tank?
Yes, I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
When there's a hole, there's a goal.
I don't understand why don't- why don't just like...
Cross out the 4 and like rewrite the number.
This man, spotted inside the stolen tank, has been identified as Rau.
He's alive!
The 61 year old sheriff of a- Oh, he's 61?
North of the Central District.
Known as Up.
However, when we ran the fingerprints of this Sheriff Rau through a centralized database, we discovered a far more shocking truth.
Rau was a mere alias.
Oh my god!
That's you!
You were the one that committed war crimes!
Mercy?
He literally killed off an entire alien race.
General Shiva?!
Oh my god, he's like Soldier 76.
That's what the S is for.
S for Shiva.
Teria Shiva!
That's his wife!
You killed your wife?!
Sexy Teria!
I love how her name is Sexy Teria.
I thought she was sexy too though.
But if she was your wife, why a magazine clipping?
Good man!
Yeah, where's your personal photos of her?
Oh!
That's so sad!
Bro!
He's fucking...
He puts...
Bro!
You can't have private alone happy time in the tank with a real photo of her.
He has to fucking make do with a magazine.
Hunter looked the maddest on us at least.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And while you're at it, tell the news office to double the reward for Shiva!
And to make an announcement that anyone found sheltering him will be subdued!
You're totally punished!
Y-yes sir!
Shiva...
What are you up to?
Ha!
Can you explain this?
You told me we'd gotten rid of Shiva!
What the fuck is this baby?
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
Random well-being checkup.
How you been, Doki?
Here's $50 dues!
Get yourself some bread, mate!
Maybe some bami too!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
I'm doing great!
Playing a nice, amazing game from Toriyama and Bandai with my dragoons!
Get your... voice down!
He looks like a dumpling!
He does!
General Shiva?
You mean... that?
Wait, is that like his son or something?
Do they have kids?
Must have kids, right?
Whoa!
Going to be fighting a legend?
Oh my god, he's so happy about it!
Oh my god, that gets him on...
That makes him a bit way too excited!
Reinforce our defenses at all locations!
I like the tank on the far back, like the one with the dot eyes, and he's just like...
He's just happy to be there!
He doesn't even know what he's... actually, no, he doesn't even know what's going on!
That tank behind him!
Wait, let me see if there's a fast travel.
That's the plan here.
Yeah!
Why?
Oh my god, he's gonna spread some propaganda!
GoldenHell, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
That is Kano after too many Mortal Kombat-backs.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Ginger!
A grandpa phone diaper?
No!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I told you, it's just like anime...
Oh my god, those are some fucking tanks to simulate into!
Don't worry.
Wait, who's calling for help right now?
I like how, like, there's an army here, and then there's like a guy that's being fucking...
um... harassed by raptors.
I'm just gonna run him over.
It's not killing if I run him over!
It's just an accident.
Nice.
Is there materials for me?
Can I simulate into this?
Oh, I can!
Okay, let me kill these raptors real fast.
For them.
There we go.
Money!
Oh, those kids are still alive.
Phew!
The kids were alive.
It's just a prank!
It's not murder!
Why do people always say murder?
I don't understand why people think it's murder when something just dies beside me.
Like, what if they just had a heart attack and I was just in the wrong place at the wrong time?
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
I didn't know that iggoons were in this game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
It's only attempt... yeah, it was only an attempt because he survived.
They died?
Yeah, they died!
They could have just had a heart attack!
Bring them down one by one!
You don't know that!
Like...
They could literally just have a heart attack!
Looks like we're in for a fight.
Okay, we gotta make sure we... Okay, first off, we have to make sure we hit those.
Alright, nice, we got this tank.
And then we gotta get that tank.
Alright, they're only level 7.
They're practically like babies.
Okay, then we gotta...
shoot the people.
You know, my fucking controller aim ain't so bad.
See, look!
I did it!
Everything I touch dies.
It's not my fault.
Doki's tank vs.
coffee!
New measurement.
Who would win?
Oh shit, loot!
Loot, loot, loot, loot, loot, loot!
Yay!
Wow!
That's so much stuff for my new tank!
Just run over it.
It doesn't matter to me.
Yeah.
Alright.
I know, it's gonna be so fucking easy.
Is this like...
Oh my god!
There's my taxi!
Oh, it's just a...
Oh, it's just a shop.
Uh, do I have anything I need to buy?
I guess I'll buy another repair kit.
I feel like that's the only thing I need.
Yeah!
Wait, there's a base there!
I might as well!
God, I wish I could steal that guy's dinosaur.
It's so much faster than a tank.
You cause the heart attacks when they gaze upon you, so...
No, no, no!
It's not my fault they died because I look so fucking...
fine.
Like, come on!
Is that truly a crime?
Because I look so beautiful that they died of heart attacks.
Like, come on!
It's cause they died of pure beauty.
It's not a crime.
So, what are you gonna tell everyone?
The truth.
And what's been on my mind.
What's on your mind, old man?
I've got a bad... bad feeling about this.
Beauty is a crime!
We should keep our distance from the army base unless necessary.
I bet they've got loads of loot in there!
I know!
They have so much loot!
I can't argue with that.
But somehow I doubt they'd take kindly to intruders.
I'm gonna not listen to him.
I'm gonna run up.
Can't talk you out of it.
Please, at least try to be sneaky about it.
Sensei, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Do I have to be sneaky?
I'm gonna pretend I didn't hear what he said.
I'm gonna go straight in.
When the terrain's to your disadvantage, keep moving until you're in a position.
I'm gonna try to get to the right spot.
No, I don't need that move.
That won't stop me exactly!
Look at that!
If I run away, I can't level up, you idiot!
God, old man, it's all about the levels!
Okay, I almost got it.
Oh, nice!
See, look at that!
Nothing to worry about!
Oh shit!
Okay, I did miss.
Here we go.
And then... whoop!
I told you guys.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Who needs stealth?
Who needs stealth when I have all this fucking loot?
Oh, I can rob them too!
Give me a sec.
We're gonna go to the...
We're gonna go to the base and rob them.
Give me a sec, guys.
This is very important.
Weeeeee!
There should be nobody here anymore, cause I...
Didn't kill them!
They ran away!
Loot!
Yes!
Got more loot!
Loot, loot, loot, loot, loot!
Why would I run away when I know I'm better?
Are there Royal Army soldiers all over Sandland?
There's even a bunch near our village!
Most of them are stationed near the Royal Capital.
It can be a lot more hit and miss the farther you get away from them.
No, I can't.
You'll also see supply units traveling around as they transport goods to bases.
Those are probably the ones who passed near our village.
Alright.
Nice.
Look at all the loot I got!
If I listened to him...
Wait, can I beat this...
Ugh!
There we go.
If I had listened to him, I wouldn't have got all this good loot.
How do I get up there though?
I should grab the tank.
Loot, loot, loot.
Stealth is for the weak?
Exactly!
Stealth is for people who are weak and don't know how to...
And know they can't beat them up by pure strength.
Stealth is for cowards!
Yeah, this is why you don't listen to Elder.
They don't know what's good for you.
Your information is outdated.
It's because this old man is so fucking weak.
So that's why he was not confident in beating the army up.
Let me grab this...
Oh my god!
I can have a dino!
Alright, guys.
This is mine.
This is better.
Better.
Like what do I do with the camp?
Anyway...
Like I don't need a rest because I never get off the...
I never get off the fucking tank.
Finally...
Riding my true...
Riding my true vehicle.
The guy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Let's see...
Barret, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
You caused a heart attack when they gazed upon you, so...
Murder!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
They can look away!
Just close your eyes!
How do you get murdered?
Wait,
he has a shield.
Does the shield actually...
stop a fucking cannon shot?
They do?
Wait, who is that?
Wait, oh that's the general!
General Ace.
Are you ready for this?
Like you have to ask!
How many times must I tell you to address him as Prince Beelzebub?
Ok, I'm curious if this stops the fuck...
Ok, it does not...
Hahaha, I was gonna say, like...
How the fuck is like...
How the fuck does the fucking...
Shield stop a cannon?
That's actually...
Like, that's very...
Oh, that's my guy.
Sorry.
I accidentally stopped...
I accidentally shot Rao.
Whoops!
My bad!
That was Rell, guys.
I'm sorry!
He needs to paint his tank a different color!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Vtubers are so cute!
I think it's like cute!
God, I wish women were real.
I know, man.
It's too bad.
It's too bad Vtubers aren't real and women aren't real either.
We're all just AI.
They read us like a book.
This commander is a pro.
So you're saying this was all for nothing?
No, I think we can get it fixed.
We all know women on the internet aren't real.
It's all just men with voice changers.
We can use this to find out about the area!
We can repair it!
Can I repair it?
I have so much materials!
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I've been scavenging for so long.
There's no way I don't have materials.
Am I
a man?
Yes.
Women aren't real on the internet, guys.
This is Shiva.
Former General Shiva.
I have something I want to tell the people of this country.
If you'll let me transmit it.
Yes.
Right away, please.
We have just received radio contact from a man claiming to be General Shiva himself.
I'm sorry.
What?
He has a message for you all.
And while we have not been able to confirm his identity, we have agreed to transmit his words live on air.
Don't worry, I'll always be your bro.
I'm actually surprised they let them trans... like... let them transmit his message.
First, allow me to sincerely apologize to you all for any distress I may have caused.
All units, cut the engines!
Make it quiet!
I freely confess to the crime of stealing a tank.
But unlike what you were told previously, I have not attacked any villages with it.
I swear this on my life.
Yeah, I'm Brokey Bird.
I'll always be your bro, bro.
It is not my aim to spread panic and confusion amid this country.
I intend only to find the legendary spring which I assure you is no mere dream.
It is a mere fairy tale.
For this country cannot withstand any more drought.
Spring?
Did he say spring?
What is he even talking about?
So please, just allow me to finish this mission without interference.
When I find the spring, I promise to make its location public...
Okay, but like, is this like the only spring in the whole fucking world?
Wouldn't that be like...
I feel like the spring will get like quickly depleted.
Because humans are greedy.
There's no way the spring is gonna feed the entire population in Sad Land.
...on an entirely different subject.
Though this doesn't absolve my role in causing that explosion 30 years ago, I've learned the truth behind it.
Yeah, it would be a good idea to...
It would dry up in like a week.
Wouldn't it?
It could be a legendary spring.
Oh my god.
Just say it.
Why didn't you just fucking call him out?
I'd call him out.
I'd be like, bro, guys, by the way, I sort of committed like an extreme war crime because like I didn't save you guys and we actually wiped off the only race that was gonna give us free water.
Fuck you, General whatever your name is, because I already forgot you're that irrelevant to me.
Contact the news office immediately.
Tell them that they are never to allow that criminal to speak freely on air again.
This is bad, isn't it, Zeyu?
He said something about the truth behind that explosion.
Why didn't he just reveal it?
This is the only time he's ever gonna be allowed in the air.
Like...
He should have just revealed everything.
He don't want to slander anyone.
He literally said, I will never forgive you, Commander Zuu.
Like, they're just gonna censor him now.
Alright, phew.
Alright.
I feel like I can upgrade my tank now for now, right?
I have so much materials.
I have so much mats.
I must be able to.
Alright, better Dragoon.
What do you need, baby?
Better Dragoon doesn't need anything.
He's already better.
Your vehicle is too low level?
Oh my...
This is why your Dragoon...
This is why your Dragoon won.
Let's see.
You're too low level for even upgrades.
I need...
Neglected again.
He's already perfect.
I'm gonna...
Can I just jump down?
Okay, look.
I know we learned that we can't.
But like...
What if I...
Wait.
Can I just fast travel?
Oh no.
It's like right over here.
But what if I like...
Watch this.
It's gonna be like...
I'm gonna Skyrim this.
That's why you know I'm a gamer.
That's why you guys watch me.
You know other VTubers won't do this.
I make my own pathways.
I don't follow what society tells me to.
Does that even...
No way.
No, they don't believe this.
That's good.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
That's it for the...
Oh noises.
We have more to talk about here.
Where the Chen is the...
Oh, so the answer is fake.
The hint says excuse me, tables, one.
Oh, okay.
Where else should we talk about this situation.
...
So...
His father was killed in that explosion?
Wait, what if he's like secretly the son?
Is he like... is this guy 30?
He has daddy issues and the other guy's a dad.
He...
Do your thing!
He's got right at the midpoint between Shiva and the royal army.
Got it, papa.
There's so many dads.
It's Shiva!
All tanks, prepare to remodel!
It's like the first bomb in Fallout!
Enemy tank brigade!
Oh my god!
They started it!
What?
They're like Vault-Tec!
Prepare to engage!
Hurry!
They shot first!
Dadland!
I love how
each tank has like different eyes.
War never changes.
Prince, take cover behind the rocks and swing around in the other direction to attack them!
Wait, which... which rock?
Whoa!
Which rock though?
Oh, I'm so happy!
I'm so happy!
Oh, there's so many rocks!
There's so many rocks!
Wait, is this mine?
This is mine.
Sorry.
I couldn't tell.
Wait, where's the other tank?
Whoa!
That's the other tank!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, he also missed!
Nice.
Is that it?
It's okay.
He's okay.
My tank's okay.
Yeah, where's the commander?
Whoa!
There he is!
Wait, why does his tank get to be a different color?
It's not fair!
If I kill the commander, do I win?
Oh my god, I'm so... Oh, it won't end.
I actually have to take him out.
Where's the blind spot?
Where did he go?
Oh shit.
Okay, did I hit him?
Alright.
If I go up here...
He can't get me.
That's not him.
Alright, he can't hit me from here.
Oh shit!
Guys...
Oh my god.
Thank god I like...
I repaired it in time.
Rouse!
Shoot your son!
It's okay!
This might be like your very last, like, remaining relative.
Because you killed your wife as well.
But you might as well kill your son.
You know?
Double whammy.
What's the minimum to survive?
So I promised my village that I would find the legendary spring.
Oh my god.
He does so much damage.
What the fuck?
Did you truly believe that such a spring exists?
Unbelievable.
He's superhuman.
What do you mean he?
I did majority of the work.
He completely disabled our unit with zero loss of life!
He was exactly the man my father said he was.
Oh, his father said he was?
Oh, so that means he was... that's not the son then.
Because he's like, oh my father said he was... so he actually talked to his dad.
I finished this so fast that we even get to hear 50% of that dialogue.
You mentioned the truth behind the explosion 30 years ago.
What is it?
You may not want to hear it.
I believe it, but I've got no hard proof.
I am Aure, the son of Apo, one of your very own officers.
Please, tell me.
I need to know the truth of my father's death.
Apo's son, eh?
I see.
Very well then.
Who's Apo?
Thief.
You're our source.
He should hear it from you.
You've got to be.
Must I do everything around here?
Bro, all you do is sit around.
Don't tell me you heard this story from him?
Yeah, he's the demon.
You take the word of a demon?
That doesn't kill.
If you won't listen to me, you won't be able to hear me.
I'm not going to listen to what he has to say.
I can't force you.
But let me say this.
In this whole twisted world, I haven't met anyone as honest as these two.
That's like...
That's so fucked up.
I consider them like fucking demons.
They might as well just not be demons at that point.
I trust them far, far more than any human at least.
Like what the fuck is the point of having demons if you're not more evil than humans?
Like...
Just like how our fear and suspicion of the peachy caused terrible tragedy.
Demons should be like the benchmark of evil.
Not the fucking middle.
What do you mean by that?
Yeah, he means humans are worse.
We're at the point where like humans are worse than demons.
Ugh!
Bunch of spineless cowards!
What's happening in this game?
It's so confusing.
We're in a land filled with sand.
And there's tanks.
And we're trying to find water.
Because it's all sand.
The end.
Guppy!
Do your thing!
Damn it!
What the fuck?
What?
You can do that?
Why can't I do that in game?
What was that just now?
No.
Don't tell me there was another tank.
It came from somewhere above us.
I'll hop up high and look around.
Don't worry it's parkour time.
I can't believe that humans are worse than demons now.
Like what's the point of being a demon?
Might as well be a human.
Like they already fucking took our jobs.
The humans took our fucking jobs.
It's the swimmers!
Those little...
He's gonna swear.
Beelzebub spotted us!
Grr!
Time to split!
Dang it!
They got away again!
I'm gonna pulverize them next time!
That Beelzebub just saved our lives.
As any demon would do.
Perhaps it's true that we've misjudged the demons.
Alright, I'll hear it.
Tell me the story of what caused the explosion 30 years ago, thief.
Nope.
Not till I hear the magic word.
Please?
What?
You let me go?
You little imp!
Who do you think you're?
Silence you!
Beelzebub?
Please just tell me!
Please?
That's so attractive.
Please sir?
Tell me please!
I'm begging you on my knees!
Please!
Please sir?
That's so true!
No!
Surely that can't be true!
Please, Donkey, please!
I know commanders say you as a cold man.
But I can't believe he could be so inhuman.
Well, we've said our piece.
And sorry, but it looks like we'll have to borrow the tank a bit longer.
But it
looks like we'll have to borrow the tank a bit longer.
Sir, are you sure?
Should we really be letting Shiva go like this?
Yes, we trust him!
What do you mean by that?
We never had him to begin with.
Bro, we literally beat the shitter of him!
And he hadn't even finished his dialogue!
He didn't even finish his plot!
We almost did.
Until the swimmers struck out of nowhere, that is.
They took out our tanks.
Then fled.
That is what happened.
Sir, yes sir!
Oh my god, he's gonna lie!
I'm gonna report to Supreme Commander Zeyu.
No.
There's something I have to confirm with the King first.
He's gonna blame the swimmers!
Oh my god!
Finally!
To pick well...
I was gonna say, why can't I do that?
How did I fucking suddenly realize I learned how to throw rocks?
I feel like I should know how to throw rocks originally.
It took so long.
Use R, B and then pick B to pick up a boulder from the ground.
Interpret one.
Throw them...
Okay.
Yay!
We can head south.
Let's go!
Time to head south!
They're already here.
That was easy.
We did it.
I'm stronger now.
Oh, you're right.
I leveled up.
I guess.
It's the ocean.
It's the sand ocean.
Roiling quicksand everywhere you look.
One wrong step and you'll be swallowed up.
Don't worry.
I'm light as a feather.
Okay, we started to prove that that was not true.
Bro,
he forgot that we drowned in the sand water?
Anyway, we can't proceed south unless we figure out how to get past this one.
We're gonna get water dragoons!
How are we supposed to do that?
Even the prince...
We're gonna be like a dragoon boat!
None of our bots will help either.
The tank or jump bot would only be even worse off.
If it didn't happen in the cutscene, doesn't count.
So true.
It would be easy if we could just fly over it.
But with planes outlawed...
Yeah, but how would they know?
How would they know that?
What if we just, you know...
Oh, I like those geckos!
I can run on water!
Explain, please.
It kinda felt like I was sinking more slowly while I was running.
Aha!
Cross before sinking to the point of no return, eh?
Prince, thief, let's head back to Spino.
Let me guess...
And to the rescue again?
What's wrong with letting Anne help?
It's because she...
Oh my god, he's fucking sexist because she's a woman, isn't she?
Alright, let's see...
Spino, where's Spino?
Why is he so against having Anne help us?
She's like...
One of the three women we met here.
Oh my god, shit.
Wait...
Let's see...
Where the fuck is Spino?
Oh, there it is.
I was like, where's Spino?
The giant checkpoint right there?
There's like three women in Sandland.
Closing up shop already?
Yeah.
There's someone I have to meet right now.
Someone from the Royal Army?
Or maybe the news office?
Why would you think that?
You've been acting strange ever since the warning about the...
Oh my god, she's gonna rat us out for money!
...the time she's been hiding here.
I'm sure you've figured out who we are by now.
You saw right through me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
So you were planning on ratting us out in the Royal Army?
How dare she!
After everything we've been through!
You put in a whole town in here.
You're in danger by letting you people stay here.
Your concerns are justified.
We don't intend to cause you good people any trouble.
We promise to never come back here.
Get her!
Now we have two women left in Sandland.
Just please, allow Anne to keep staying here.
She's a personal guest of Mayor Torr's.
And had no part in the theft of the...
What do you mean, you people?
Well, in that case, fine.
Hold on.
We all busted out of the base in that tank to get...
Prince, thief, let's get going.
No!
This is our only home!
We're gonna miss that garage.
It was like our secret hideout.
I didn't get a chance to customize this town!
I got 50 chairs!
Let's not be so...
What am I gonna do with 50 chairs?
Mayor Torr!
80s...
Don't you know what these people are doing?
They've been trying to find a spring.
And not just for their own personal benefit, mind you.
They're trying to help everyone.
Yeah, all five people in this town.
Sorry, four soon after Anne's gone.
Sorry to add, 80s is after 80s is gone, too.
Probably.
But I can't stand the sight of people who stand by as the people of this nation suffer any longer.
Even if it means putting your life at risk.
That is not my name anymore.
Yeah, it's Raurr.
Raurr.
I'm pretty sure in Japanese it sounds a lot better.
In English it's so hard to pronounce.
Raurr.
You heard the man.
How about this, 80s?
Toriyama style game.
It's the last game Toriyama was involved in.
To be fair, 30 million yen I would turn myself into.
Not 30 million.
30 million zen.
I love how it's called zen.
Instead of yen.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Two of the four villages.
Oh, DK12 might be the last one.
But one of them does not care about a single thing.
So, I've been looking around.
I'll go with another team.
Really?
Yes, please.
But the party I'm going to is the Goa, where I'll be going with my friends.
Oh, I see.
But you like your party.
So do I.
Tsk.
I'll take my place.
I'm sorry we gave you the wrong idea.
Oh my god!
She's getting welcomed in the community!
Oh, they don't know it.
We'll know they're isolating her already.
Hahaha!
Whoa!
I like how we're like, yeah, we're eavesdropping.
I'm glad you'll be standing guard at the garage.
And stay put.
Leave convincing the villagers to us.
You got it!
It's only two other villagers.
You might have to wait for a bit, but we owe her an apology.
As we stand in front of her?
I like how we just listen to it in front of her.
80s!
Fuck you, 80s!
Is it true that you want to report Shiva?
Yeah!
How dare you!
How else am I gonna look at that hot lady working on cars?
Yeah, that's right.
I would have done it too.
If Mayor Twain hadn't stopped you.
If it wasn't for those meddling kids.
And he was right too.
We won't submit to the Royal Army's threats, even if it kills us.
Oh, are you still carping about that?
The Civil War is long since over.
For 30 years...
Exile her!
She wants to get rid of Anne!
The Royal Army is still the same bunch of jackbooted thugs they were back then.
And I won't stop fighting until that changes.
Good grief.
Once his temper flares, all you can do is wait for him to cool down on his own.
Just leave him be.
That said, I don't think we should report General Shiva either.
He may have been our enemy in the past, but he's...
Yeah!
He's reformed!
He's old!
He's like 60!
What's he gonna do?
We can push him!
If the elderly starts acting up, just push them!
I trust him.
Don't push the elderly in real life, guys.
Don't do that.
Don't listen to Doki advice.
Sometimes they might be bad.
If he takes the royals down a peg in the process, I can die happy.
Hold on.
Do you still hate the Royal Army too, then?
You have to ask?
Like I'd ever forgive them for leaving my hometown in ruins.
I think I know where I stand now.
Vegeta's like 60.
Yes, he's 60, but he's still a saint!
He's not a real person!
Like...
Sorry.
He's not a human.
He's still... He's like... That's like...
In like, Saiyan age.
Whoa there.
Are they all talking without me?
Oh, he's crying.
Why are you crying?
What's wrong, Fleeka?
Did you wet the bed again or something?
No...
It's just that...
Everyone in town seems mad and...
I'm scared.
Oh my god, for once I can actually talk in this conversation.
Instead of eavesdropping.
Betty, Vegeta is a real... Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To be fair, the Saiyans, we're sort of like...
Didn't really have rights for a very long time.
To be fair.
But I don't want you or Beelzebub to go.
Maybe you should tell everyone that.
Okay.
She's a good kid.
It's thanks to all of you that she could grow up to be so kind and carefree.
Hmm...
I suppose you could say it takes a village, huh?
We don't want to disturb the community you've built here.
Fleeka considers all of you a part of that community too, you know.
This cruel world only ever seems to take more and more away from us.
That's why the rare gifts...
Why can't I give them my chairs?
I bought the... I bought the deluxe version for the chairs.
I'm just not sure we're right to take advantage of such kindness.
I think we've heard enough.
I got 50 chairs and 50 windows apparently.
Like can I start customizing this goddamn town?
It seems we have our verdict now.
Seems like it.
Who knew hatred for the royal army ran so deep?
Not deep enough for 80s apparently.
Well that came out wrong.
See?
There are others who support your cause.
Sounds like we really gotta find that spring now.
Guess so.
Alright, we gotta find water.
Can I talk to you now?
Hey Anne, you gotta build us the fastest ride ever.
I'm fine, thanks for asking.
Sounds fun, but I need the deets.
You see, some intense quicksand is blocking our path south of here.
We need something that can zip across it before it sinks.
Well, can't you use your car?
It's too slow.
The sand would swallow it up.
Hmm...
We need something faster.
Maybe my bike might work.
Your bike?
Too bad I don't have it.
Wait, what happened to this perp- oh yeah, we lost a bike.
That's helpful.
We need Chase with the Royal Army back in Talbot.
Is a bike faster than water sand?
Couldn't you fix it if you had one of those core-frame wutzits?
Yeah.
Sure, but I haven't recovered that from the wreck.
We'll have to go get it.
Then, that's what we'll do!
Where is it?
Yeah, where is it?
I was pretty focused on just getting away.
So I've only got a rough idea.
I know it should be somewhere north of Talbot at least.
How specific?
But I think I'll be able to remember more once we get closer.
Good.
Let's go together.
Sorry, I didn't quite catch that.
What did you say?
We're going together!
I said, let's go together.
Yeah, you're not dead weight!
I'm not dead weight!
That has to be a key for something.
That looks like the most key thing in the world.
It has to be a fucking key.
Oh, hush.
Let's get going already.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta find the bike.
Oh, I gotta customize.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta upgrade our parts.
Ok, parts.
Make part.
Can I customize my weapon?
Let's see, but like...
I don't know if like my stuff is stronger.
That's the thing.
I don't remember what my parts were technically.
Wait, did I install it?
My tank too low still?
Your level is still too low?
And you upgrade my vehicle?
Oh my god, how much...
What level does this vehicle need?
Customized vehicle...
Uh, yes.
I need to level up you.
Okay, level up vehicle.
Upgrade vehicle.
Alright, Dragoon 1.
It's time to get upgraded.
Are you strong enough now?
You have to be.
I wasted so many mats on you.
Okay, parts.
Upgrade part.
Can you...
Oh, thank god!
Okay.
I can upgrade you, right?
No, I don't...
God damn it.
I can't even upgrade you anymore.
Oh, wait.
Is that better?
28.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Upgrade you?
God damn it!
What the fuck is Crocsteel?
What's Crocsteel?
Okay, let's see.
We're gonna upgrade you.
Upgrade.
And then...
Yeah, but what is it?
Alright, I think that's all the parts.
I'm pretty sure.
Is it?
Is there anything else?
Whoa.
We gotta sell some parts though.
We're like...
Yeah, I think that's everything.
Alright.
Weeeeee.
Let's see.
Is that like quest?
Like a mini quest right here?
What is this?
Hello, 80s.
That was me.
It was!
You truly are a lifesaver.
Hmph.
Don't know what you're talking about.
A lifesaver that you're gonna ride out!
Can't you just let her think?
Yeah, silence you rat!
I've got new wares available thanks to you.
Oh, new items?
Okay, nevermind.
Everything bad I said about you, I was just joking.
I was just joking.
He he.
Adhesive, clay.
Oh, these are just...
What about Crocsteel?
You have Crocsteel?
Can I like sell my materials?
Or parts?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Guys, I actually forgot which ones are the ones I don't need.
I was like, aww, I don't remember!
I don't remember!
Oh, okay, we're just gonna...
I don't remember which one I wanna sell, so we're just gonna hoard it, I guess.
No, thank you for the...
Five gift of ships, thank you, thank you!
Alright, I already forgot which one I...
Thank you for coming!
I don't remember which one I wanted to have to sell, so I'm just gonna...
We're just gonna hoard everything, might as well.
We don't need the money anyway.
I feel like we farm so much that we don't even need the money.
I think we'll be fine.
Alright, time to ride my dino.
Okay, I'm gonna ride the dino.
I'm gonna steal the dino.
And then I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be back, guys!
I'm back!
I have to kick out...
I have to kick out Doki Ambri Doge real quick.
Because he like, sneaked into my room.
Alan, Maddy, and Ari and Gladstone, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Oh, it's this way.
Wait, is there a fast travel for this?
This has to be a fast travel, right?
Yeah.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
No, my dinos!
I can feed up the cow.
Wait, I can feed up the cows now!
No!
The cows!
That's looking right.
Leave!
Leave this town!
Now this town has no food anymore.
You're welcome.
I'm gonna grab the tank.
Scorpions, leave if you know what's good for you!
Oh my god, they like, died.
They died so fast.
Nice!
One down!
I like, I interrupted her.
Well, obviously that's not fucking...
That's not the crocs deal I need.
Be gone, silly cows!
Now this town will not have any food anymore.
You're welcome.
How could you, Doki?
Oh shit, I can farm cactuses?
Oh, that's nice to know.
Wait, whose car is this?
Wait, oh that's a bad car!
Oh shit!
That's a bad car!
Alright, that was a car.
That was a car.
He was just doing some fucking sick drifts.
And I like, interrupted him.
Alright, these guys who are slowly running towards me.
These were guys that were slowly running towards me.
Sounds tough.
This is my home now.
Things are better now.
Haha!
Nice, now I get to rob them.
What kind of region are we in?
Well, there should be a few towns, an army base, and a bandit hideout around here.
Oh, there's a radio tower?
Soldiers and bandits.
Now he's drifting in heaven.
I interrupted their fucking drift session.
Don't let your guard down.
Don't
you see that you left the bikes somewhere around these parts?
It's okay.
That raptor can join us.
We're in another family.
I killed him in the cutscene?
Look,
they're the invasive species.
These raptors.
Oh my god!
He took it!
Speaking of which, I've heard that pteranos build their nests out of metal.
Oh, they like harvested a bike.
That's true.
Then maybe one of them took my bike?
It's Metal Gear!
That's quite possible.
Then we should go after it.
It's already out of sight.
Not to worry.
They like to nest on rocky cliffs just like these.
Let's head after it and see if we can find a way up those cliffs.
Here we go.
Pteranodon is very sensitive to movement and shiny objects.
That's okay.
I know parkour.
It only takes the slightest stimulation to draw their attention.
Watch this.
If only it was so easy to get the prince to pay attention.
Wait, what is that supposed to mean?
I pay attention?
Okay, guys.
I might need some assistance.
Now watch this.
Wait, how was I supposed to know I'd be too short?
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
I'm gonna provoke them.
Watch this.
I'm gonna shoot them out of the sky.
Nice.
See?
I told you.
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your very first super.
Thank you again.
Alright.
Up I go.
Wait, is that item?
Wait, that's loot.
Look.
An egg.
The inside of the shell is full.
Wait, is she like...
Oh, I was gonna say, did she like harvest somebody's fucking egg?
I was gonna be like, that's so fucked up.
And...
Alright, up we go.
I can't believe it.
It's free too.
We fixed the...
We fixed the pterodactyl population.
Population.
The Pterodactyl population.
Yeah!
Oh, there it is!
There's the eggs!
Wonder where the babies went.
There's more loot!
I'm gonna make this jump.
Weeeee!
I knew I would make it.
Oh my god, look at all these fucking free shit.
I love free shit.
Check.
I just need Croc Steel.
I have no... I still have no idea which one's Croc Steel.
Okay.
Alright, we need to swap to...
We need to swap to a tank.
Oh, that's nice that I just noticed that like...
When you're in the tank, you can swap to like...
You don't have to get off and swap.
That way.
That's so convenient.
That's your bike!
How the fuck did it get rusted so fast?
It's like two days!
It's like two to three days!
Oh shit!
I didn't kill your kids, I swear.
Yeah!
They just flew up and flew away from the nest.
I swear to god.
I swear I didn't do anything to your kids!
Oh god.
I mean, to be fair, everything is red.
I would assume it breathes fire because it's red.
Just like how blue breathes ice and yellow breathes electricity.
Whoa!
He's a fucking...
Oh shit!
Get him while he's down!
Shoot him in the dick!
Oh shit!
Whoa!
There you go.
I think I did it.
Now run him over with the tank.
If Scrappy-Doo can...
If the whole plot of Velma Season 2 is that Scrappy-Doo bit off people's dicks, then I can shoot somebody in the dick.
Come at me with all you got then!
Wait!
Stop right there!
Seriously?
Wait!
About what?
Oh, now you care about animals?
Now you condone animal cruelty?
Oh, it's like the eggs.
Don't worry.
Those aren't what we're after.
He's telling the truth.
We just want my motorcycle back.
He's like, I can understand.
He's like, I see.
Okay.
The negotiators.
Wait, I got the wings.
How the fuck did I get the wings if like I didn't kill?
What do you think about it?
Like that doesn't make sense.
I didn't get the...
How would I grab a piece of their wing?
They grew ba- Oh yeah, you're right.
They grew back.
Alright,
I think I- Oh, I can level up now.
Alright, what do I wanna... Okay, what is this?
I wanna max HP.
And then... Increase potency.
Raises Beelzebub's attack when...
Increase deployment speed for Beelzebub's specific items.
Boost powers of B- I might as- Oh wait, I don't have enough- Oh, I have two- Oh, I have one more.
Okay.
Maybe the rush.
Oh wait, I already did that.
Oh, I need three for that.
Oh.
Okay, I'm just gonna save up then.
Uh...
Detect hidden items.
Okay, we need that.
We need the hidden item shit.
Increase the chance of enemies dropping rare parts.
Hell yeah!
I need more Crocs to ya!
We don't care about the old man.
I need all the loot!
Do you need anything?
Yeah.
I need...
to make...
parts, apparently.
For the bike.
Who the fuck cares about the car?
Okay, the bike.
Oh my god, I can put a cannon on the bike?
Let's go.
Alright, nice and in suspension.
Yeah, I'm not gonna build the car.
I don't care about the car that much.
Uuuuuhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh...
Can I do this?
Okay, make vehicle.
Okay, motorbike.
Toot.
Boop.
And then...
Okay.
Make it.
Wait, do I not have enough money?
I don't have enough money?!
See you later.
I need to pay you to make your own bike?!
What?!
Okay, I got...
I'm broke.
I gotta sell something.
Stop.
Alright, give me a sec.
I gotta sell something.
I can't believe I have to pay her!
That's so bullshit!
Okay, $77.
I'm just gonna sell this.
Well, I don't know!
I thought I had a lot of money too!
God damn it!
Jimmy.
This is your own bike!
You should fucking...
You should...
Not gonna lie, but she should actually like...
You know...
Actually help out?
I don't have Raptor's Seal?!
Bro, you should chip in!
It's your fucking bike!
Like...
It's literally hers!
I have to kill some Raptors real quick, guys.
Like, apparently I don't have Raptors.
I don't have enough Raptor's Steel to put this together.
How is she gonna get parts without money?
This is so bullshit!
I have to kill some more...
Babies!
Oh my god, if I could, I would fucking...
I would knock out the merchant and then...
I would knock out the merchant and farm his Raptor.
Is that fucked up?
Goodbye...
Goodbye, little guy.
I got a question.
Why can humans eat some plants but not others?
Our bodies can't digest a lot of them.
Oh, it's a green Raptor!
And then there's others that are downright...
Well, so it goes!
Oh my god, it's like a Meerkat!
All right, I did it.
No green skill?
Wait, I don't want the green skill.
I need the red one, right?
Wait, I need the red one.
Oh my god, I killed the family for no reason!
It's not even the right raptor!
Where the fuck is the red one?
Oh, there they are.
Okay, there's the red ones.
Alright.
Oh my god, they're like meerkats.
Like meerkat raptors.
They don't... They're all weak to the fucking missiles.
That's all I need to know.
I like how the range for this is so low.
Alright, this has to be the raptor scale, right?
The raptor scale?
There we go.
Oh my god, finally!
Okay, we're going back.
We did it.
I got the right family.
We've harvested the right family.
Do you need any?
Yes, please make the vehicle.
We're gonna make your own bike.
Wait, is raptor steel not raptor scale?
Oh my god.
How do I get raptor steel?
This fucking sucks.
My literacy got the better of me again.
Do you sell raptor steel?
You don't even sell raptor steel.
Thank you for coming.
I can't believe it.
Through a side quest?
Which one?
There's so many.
Oh my god.
Alright guys, I gotta go fucking do a side quest.
I have to craft it?
Alright, we gotta figure out which side quest was the crafting one.
Um...
I have...
Okay, is it the commander Ardia?
The da- wait, what?
Okay, which one is water supply point gifted flowers?
Which one's our quest?
Junker market...
Okay, the junk pit.
Is it the junk pit?
Let's see, can I fast travel this?
I can, thank god.
Okay.
Uhhh...
Alright, get in here.
It's not that?
Oh my god.
Okay, where's my quest log?
Okay, which one?
Alright, these are the quests I completed.
Alright.
Okay, there's the junk pit.
Okay, I completed these.
Alright.
Oh, guys, I just realized there's not a lot.
I only have one side quest apparently.
Wait, where is this one?
How do I get there?
Oh, it's this way.
It's this way?
Am I heading the right way?
No, it's this way.
Guys, I got lost again.
Well, I might as well farm these fucking scorpion scales.
I don't know which one is like the quest for crafting.
What is the crafting quest called?
Chat.
Oh wait, I need to...
Uhhh...
I need to swap.
Okay, and then jump!
What?
I'm not... I can't jump high enough?
I'm not...
I can't jump high enough?
What's the point?
What's the point of having a bot that's literally for jumping when I can't even jump high enough?
That's actually crazy.
Oh, I need to go to the junker?
Alright.
I'm done with this quest.
No, I can't fast travel because the animals are angry at me!
What did I do?
I need to finish this quest first, I guess.
Oh, this has to be the quest.
Are they evil people?
Oh no, hey Ren!
You wanna talk?
Oh, you're an NPC.
You don't matter.
They all don't matter.
Weeeeee!
Oh!
Nice.
Not nice.
Get in the can.
Oh, there he goes!
Get in the tank!
Oh!
So easy!
So fucking easy, guys.
I'm stuck.
Oh!
Ooooooh!
Me?
Let me get off.
Oh no.
Oh!
Oh nooooo!
Guys, we have a little problem.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we got off.
Oh, thank god.
I was a little worried.
Oh, extra armor!
Ooh!
B-grade gunpowder!
I forgot the fuel efficiency.
We don't need that.
That shit's for losers.
Did we open that already?
How do we get out of here?
Oh, there's stairs!
I could've used the stairs.
Nice.
Yeah.
I'm assuming we jump this way, right?
Here we go.
This way?
Ooh, rock!
Okay, we always need more ores.
Ores are good for us.
I still can't believe I have to fucking make her goddamn bike.
Boop!
Is there raptor steel?
Ma'am, is there any raptor steel I can scavenge?
Here we go.
Please!
Would anyone... I wish there was multiplayer so I can just ask a dragon to trade me some raptor steel.
That would be the life.
That's all I want.
Is it this?
Oh, raptor steel!
Finally!
Who the fuck is Propta?
Okay.
That is, we need four, right?
Oh my god, thank god.
Now there's a quest here too?
Can you do me a huge favor and get me something?
Sure.
Huh?
No way.
Please?
My boss will kill me if I don't get ten pieces of iron ore.
Oh, I have ten pieces!
I've tried, I promise.
I was mining for it till just now.
Then I found a comic someone left behind at the mine.
I have iron ore?
It was really good.
I completely lost track of the time.
Is the comic really that good?
You like comics?
I'll let you read it if you bring me the ore.
Oh my god, the comics survived?
There's no trees anywhere.
Wait, yeah, it's sand.
Oh, alright.
Sure.
Wahoo!
You're the best!
Thanks, buddy.
I already have it, so I might as well.
Like, I already... Yeah, it's literally here.
Thanks, you're a lifesaver.
I did your favor.
Can I see the comic now?
Yeah, what's the comic?
Oh yeah, sure.
How good is this?
How good is the comic?
I don't even get to see it?
I gave him 10 ore!
Oh, and here's the thing I promised.
Thanks!
I can never have too many of these.
So bring some over if you have any to spare.
I'll repay you, of course.
And stock up on some new comics, too.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I didn't even... I lost 10 ore.
What did I gain from that?
It just says I lost 10 ore!
That's it?
Did I get scammed?
Like...
Have you heard of sad paper?
And the thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but doesn't that... like, that's like super fucking rough, though.
I can't believe it.
He took that... he took that and like, left me.
Okay, we have the craft.
Did I have to pay him for the craft?
No, I didn't.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say, I was gonna be so sad if I had to pay him as well.
Cause like, I'm already broke.
Alright, I completed the quest, old man.
Now give me your money.
I'm broke.
This girl's gonna take all my money soon.
I can't help as far as parts go.
But I'm sure you'll come across some sooner or later.
You gain valuable experience in not getting scammed!
Miracle, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cause, will she learn her lesson and not get scammed?
Find out next time, Sandland.
I'll think about it.
Alright.
Here it is.
Alright, time to make her fucking bike now.
I should have enough now, right?
Okay.
My new car.
There we go!
Good as new!
No, this is not a dragoon.
This is a straight up scam.
Come on, let's take it for a spin!
Alright, nice.
Wow, I got $500!
Nice, okay.
Alright.
Now we can...
Now we can leave.
Oh yeah, I should save the game.
You're right, guys.
Whoa!
There's a reason why we don't save!
I'm so sorry!
I'm sorry, guys!
Whoa.
That was crazy.
Okay, now we go... here?
Yeah.
Water supply point.
Now we can like, ride the water.
Alright, autopilot, leave vehicle, boost, shoot, aim, reload.
Oh, I have drift!
I can drift now, too.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Drifting time!
I am speeding!
I'm going so fucking fast!
You don't understand, Grandpa!
Gas, gas, gas!
Dang!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you for the scam recovery, bud!
Wait, how come he could ride through the sand with his car?
I'm gonna go up here!
Alright!
Are you ready for action, Guppy?
We're getting that bounty!
For sure this time!
Here goes!
I feel like Guppy eats all the food for these kids.
Bro, okay, somebody should take the gun away from Guppy.
Oh, he actually hit!
Did you get him?
That's like the first time I saw Guppy hit anything!
Also, he fucking shot my car that I spent so much money on!
I'm so mad!
I just made it!
More or less...
What the heck just happened?
Those idiots apparently still haven't learned.
Yoshi, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh!
Beelzebub's still alive and kicking!
Say what?
Zua...
Does he look mad?
Very.
He's glaring right at us.
Uhhh...
You two, take care of my ride.
And you?
I'm gonna beat up some old men!
I'm gonna kick some swimmer butts!
Yeah, that's the PG way of saying it.
Get over here!
Oh, no you don't!
Don't worry!
Doki mad!
It's a fight you'll get!
Here I go!
You're up against the biggest, baddest criminals in Sand Land!
Oh, wrong guy!
Wait, I did that much damage?
Are you serious?
I like that that much damage?
Oh, shit!
That's fucked up!
Where is he shooting at?
Oh my god!
Okay, guys, a guppy needs, like, help.
At this point, this might be a guppy issue.
Like...
Oh, shit!
Ow.
Wait, but he does so little damage!
I'm not scared!
Whoa!
Wait, that did nothing!
Wait, that's funny.
That actually did nothing.
Okay, let's get rid of this child first.
I feel like I should just get rid of Swimmer Papa.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Where are you?
Don't you dare dodge me!
That's right!
I'm gonna punch you in the dick because I'm at the perfect height!
Oh, shit!
Honestly, I don't think there's any point in, like, beating up the children as well.
Because, like...
What the... Wait, he doesn't...
What?!
He doesn't even notify me!
Oh, shit.
I just need to kill him.
It's okay.
Got it.
Dodge him.
Oh, I did not dodge him.
Okay, nice.
Keep dodging.
Whoop!
That's fucking right!
Haha!
He just runs!
That awesome is pissed.
That's for my bike.
I just spent money on it, too.
What I do believe in is the old man.
If he says there's a spring, I bet he's right.
I met this guy, like, a week ago.
If, and I mean if you fight it, would you maybe let us swim there, too?
Oh, that's what I call the swimmer gang!
I love how on the far left you can see the guppy's ass.
What a nice view.
We might call it the Swimmer Gang.
Swimmers.
But my sons never got the chance to splash around in a game.
Guppy is kicked up!
Somebody noticed it before I did, that's for sure.
Hahaha!
Eh, do what you like.
Just one left!
Wait, who's the one left?
Oh, the guy that's running?
What the fuck!
Hahaha!
No choice now.
Whoa!
Hahaha!
It's like, freaking, guys, it's anime Sonic now!
Oh, shit!
Oh, no!
It's okay, I dodged!
No way!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
What was your 16?
Okay, nice.
Why would that be like the right and not the left?
Like, the way some of this is...
Sonic 06!
I'm tripting.
Why do I even...
Wait, you're right!
Why do I even need a car?
I'm faster than the car!
I'm nowhere near where I started.
Yikes!
Why does he even need a bike?
I'm clearly faster than the fucking bike!
Sandstorm?
What lousy timing!
Gains a new power.
There's nowhere to hide around here!
Did we just leave that guy to die?
I like how we left the fucking...
the running kid to die.
Like, okay, yeah, and we're like, yep, we caught up with him.
Anyway...
There's a huge rocky cliff over there!
There is?
Let's hurry!
Where?
Here?
Am I hurrying enough?
Guys, this is the fastest I could go.
This is...
Crap!
We're gonna be flying!
I'm going my fastest!
Hurry!
We did it.
That was close!
Why is there light from deeper in?
Yeah, is there a secret town there?
Secret tunnel!
What?
That's the spring!
Oh my god, there's trees!
There's a turtle.
How did he get up there?
How did that turtle get up there?
I can't wait to tell the whole world about this one tiny ass lake!
Yes,
there we go.
I wonder just how far the prince got off to.
We should have made him take a walkie talkie with him.
Man!
Say something, thief!
I'm not a thief!
No, that wasn't me.
That was...
Hey!
Old man!
Prince?
Where are you shouting from?
Hello?
Did you forget about my telepathy?
Anyway, enough about that.
Guess where I am right now!
Where you at?
I don't know.
Where?
The spring!
I found your legendary spring!
We did it!
Can it be?
You really made it to the spring?
Yeah!
What?
You telling me the word of a fiend's not good enough for ya?
Sorry.
So, where is it?
It's like inside a rock.
Your mom's house.
This is Ari.
May I have a moment, sire?
What is it, General Ari?
I'm in the middle of a meal right now, you know?
Whoa!
Wait, he gets second dinner?
You hardly ever contact me to...
Oh!
Don't tell me you've gotten rid of Shiva already!
My apologies, sire.
See?
Supreme Commander Zeyu just told me something.
He said you had personally ordered him to carry out the genocide of the Pichi and the destruction of the tank brigade thirty years ago.
He what?
Why would he tell people that explosion was deliberate now of all times?
Anyway, that is a bold-faced lie.
Zeyu came up with that entire plan all on his own.
Oh my god!
You already threw him under the rock!
I see.
Yes.
I am still pursuing Shiva, sire.
Ari out.
He's getting bamboozled.
He's shifting the blame.
I can't believe it was true this entire time.
I'm just wondering, has he ever even seen a tree in grass before?
I can't believe it.
Like in his lifetime?
I know, right?
Aren't you impressed?
Okay, let's split up and look around.
Look around for what?
We found it.
Wait, where were we?
Like, this was the whole mission.
We found it.
See?
Can I run on water now?
Oh my god.
Wait, this water is like...
Oh, okay.
There we go.
I was gonna say!
I was like, this is not very deep.
Like, now I'm gonna contaminate the water.
Yeah.
Don't bathe in the water.
Just remember when you drink that water.
Oh, it's the fucking...
These houses!
It's the Toriyama houses!
What the fuck is a monkey?
Just remember when you drink that water.
Remember...
Remember who touched it.
I gotta go...
Go the other way.
Side.
I go this way.
Yeah, the water is...
The water is like tainted with...
Oh my god!
The crocs!
No!
Oh wait, nice.
Okay, I can...
It's okay.
Some people would drink it if like...
I don't wanna say it.
It was touched by feet.
It's here.
I mean, there's houses here.
Wait, are these the Pichis?
I told you!
They're like the Namek's...
From the...
From...
From Dragon Ball Z.
Now I can sell Demon Prince bathwater.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, what the fuck?
Is that supposed to be like...
The female ones?
Why do they look like that?
Yeah.
Who are you?
Get back here!
They're like evolved versions.
Like...
I am the chief of this village.
This guy looks like he's from Star Trek.
What is your business here?
In a thousand years, this is what the...
This is what they're gonna look like.
Their ears are gonna fall off.
Cause they're already bald already.
Yeah?
So like...
In a thousand plus years, their ears are gonna fall off.
And they're gonna be tiny.
I was searching for the spring.
A demon?
By yourself?
No.
I came with my friends.
Thief and Rao.
Rao?
If what we heard on the radio is correct, Isn't that the name General Shiva goes by now?
Yeah.
Then you're saying...
Shiva's at our doorstep.
Wait, he's the war criminal!
They killed him in the war!
He killed his entire family.
I mean, he still committed it!
Like...
That's not gonna exempt him!
He killed...
Maybe millions of people!
Or aliens!
He did the crime, but not the time.
Exactly!
And I have a request.
That's not how you...
That's how you forgive a war criminal.
All they have to say is...
I'm sorry.
You have my gratitude.
Need anything from the outside world?
Bet Rao would be happy to bring it by later.
Oh, that would help immensely!
I mean, Vegeta got...
Oh yeah, because he was hot!
There's many canned goods, articles of clothing, and shoes as you can get your hands on!
You got it!
He had abs too!
Hot people can get away with a lot of things!
I'm just...
He had murderers!
Okay, wait.
Can I rob them?
Do they have stuff I can steal from them?
Tourists.
Can't believe foreigners have made their way here!
Wait, I'm...
Wouldn't they be the foreigners?
Because they're literally aliens?
Like...
I don't...
Why did he call me the foreigner?
Hello.
They're literally the aliens!
They're the Pichirais.
Now they own this now.
They aren't aliens?
I thought the Pichirais were the aliens!
Like, this is my home first!
Let's see this way.
Oh, there's a chest here!
Yay!
They're second generation!
Okay, that was...
That was good.
Rob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Whenever you do warcrafts, all you do is give them a puffy face and say, I'm sorry.
What's going on?
Did you find something?
Yeah.
Some Pichirais survivors.
And their kids.
I'm sorry.
I told them the truth about what happened 30 years ago.
They're not from...
They are!
They came from under earth!
That's practically earth!
Hahaha!
They weren't wiped out after all.
Forgive me.
Prince.
I have no right to ask this of you.
But could we just leave this place?
Look, some of these Pichirais were born on this earth now.
So they're like second generation Pichirais.
So it's peace technically from earth now.
I already told the Pichirais that we'd forget we ever saw this place.
I should have known you'd say that.
Out of everyone I've met.
I've never known anyone with a soul as pure as you are.
Oh my god, for a demon?
Is that any way to compliment a fiend?
Oh right!
I asked if they wanted anything.
And they said canned food, clothes, and shoes.
What are they...
Shoes?
Clothes and shoes for?
Once this is all over, I'll load up a truck with anything I can get and deliver them here.
I can't believe we say that to the demon prince!
So, what do we do now?
We have to find the king's water source.
There's something fishy about it.
I just know it.
Yeah, it's not gonna be easy.
We don't even know where it is.
And it's definitely not a good idea.
We're definitely gonna be well protected.
Yeah, what do you need shoes for?
The radio?
Who in the world?
Hey, flip that switch to put it on speaker.
This is General Laurie.
I'm just talking to myself.
Alright?
It sure would put us in a tough spot.
But I'm not sure what to do.
If anyone were to follow the dried up river bed all the way to its southern end...
That would be pretty bad!
Oh no!
If they did, they'd find the army's water source and discover the truth of the terrible secret there.
So terrible!
And this would be especially bad timing for that considering...
But no one's gonna do that, right?
...working soldiers defending it to take some well deserved benefits.
Yeah, but no criminal's gonna be listening to this radio, right?
I could use a break myself after hearing straight from the king that the events of thirty years ago transpired exactly as thief said they did.
Hell of a shock!
I nearly burst a blood vessel!
Now I'm feeling in the mood to talk to myself as well.
There are still men of honor serving in the royal army.
I'm not sure what to do.
I can see more hope for Sandland's future than I have an idea of.
Wouldn't the main commander, Zeyu, listen in?
My thanks!
Then would he post more g- Oh my gosh.
Don't think about the plot holes too hard, Doki.
Don't think about it.
He's well aware that Zeyu will discover what he's done before long.
And that he will be punished for it.
But then why did he tell us?
What does he stand for?
To gain.
Perhaps it's in his blood.
That's a joke, China.
Scorpius.
His father was a great man too, after all.
It just works.
Oh, it's a queen!
He disappeared!
OHH!
Why is she so mad?
I don't understand!
What could she be mad about?
I don't understand.
What did I do?
What could I have possibly done?
Okay, we gotta reload.
I know!
Okay, but look at how tough the exoskeleton is!
My fucking missiles is like a little love bump, you know?
It's like a little tap.
Okay, what the fuck does this raptor wanna do?
Get out of the fight!
This doesn't concern you!
What are you doing?
There we go.
Nice.
Oh my god, get out!
Nice!
I got Queen Exoskeleton.
We gotta go here.
Real secrets no more.
Alright, we gotta fast travel Spino.
He's in the splash zone.
Wait, why is he...
Oh yeah, it's just a cat.
We gotta go this way.
Guys, how many percentage of the game have I done anyway?
I feel like not that much.
Like how much percentage of the story am I in?
You got it!
20%?!
This is 20%?!
Chapter 13?!
Wow!
Bro, this already feels like mid-game.
I feel like... I thought I was like...
I thought I was like at mid-game with the way the story was going.
Apparently I wasn't even mid-game.
I'm chapter 13 of 31.
We'll probably find traveling merchants on the main roads.
They roam over Sandland, peddling their wares to all comers.
Okay, I might need more raptors.
Travelers, huh?
If we find any, let's stop and compare notes with them.
Oh shit, okay, let's kill these guys.
Alright.
Okay, we need some other materials.
What level is my fucking car anyway?
Okay.
I mean, it's a good sign that it's like a one-shot though.
Nice, alright.
I'll get all these mats.
Gotta absorb this tank.
And then... we gotta...
To be fair, I noticed that I am missing like three more cars.
I need to upgrade my other tank too.
My better... my better dragoon.
Or... oh wait, nice ores!
I love materials.
I love mats.
Okay, get over here.
No!
At the reload!
Guys!
I fucking knew it was a PlayStation!
That he gave us!
I was like, that looks so much like a PlayStation!
It was like, whoa, whoa, you guys were like, no, Doki, it's a Saturn!
And then I read the first chapter of Sandland, and literally they were like, oh my god, it's a PlayStation!
But then of course in the game, they had to be like copyright free, so they could...
I fucking knew it!
I knew my PlayStations!
...to be any better in your day than it is now.
Translation error.
Knowing what I do now, the rebel army will teach you...
I fucking knew it!
You guys gaslit me into thinking it was a Sega Saturn.
...to believe it was built on a foundation of sand.
Including what you thought about demons?
Yeah, that too.
Wait, can I just jump up?
You opened my eyes, most of all.
Weeeeee!
It's like a slide!
It's like a little slide!
Wait, I could just use my bike!
It's literally faster!
I'm so stupid!
There we go.
I can get there faster now.
Weeeeee!
We might be able to reach these inaccessible spots one day.
Supreme Commander Zayu, we have General Aray on the line!
Hello, it's me.
Gimme that!
Can you hear me, Aray?
What kind of lies have you been telling to the King, you bastard?
The truth!
And what of Jeefa?
Have you finished him or not?
Wait, has he not listened to the radio?
I'd appreciate some confirmation that you haven't completely lost your mind!
Hello?
Sorry, it seems reception's bad here.
Can't hear what you're saying!
No response from the troops guarding the water source or General Aray!
What?
Dispatch my personal elite guard to the water source!
Oh, I thought someone was like, that dude's in an iron lung!
Stop, Jeefa!
Oh God!
According to information from the news office...
Uh, criminal organization attempted to go after the Bouti on Sheeva.
He's that strong.
Ashmeer!
He was pink, not red.
I can't believe it!
They miscolored him!
How dare he!
The insect men?
That's too dangerous!
They're not yet complete!
I don't care!
As long as they can kill Seba and that demon, they're ready enough!
I like his pink glasses.
As you wish.
Oh my god, isn't he gonna look like Cyberman?
Okay, how far is this?
Holy shit, that's far!
Wow!
Oh my god!
I wonder what they're gonna look like.
I wonder what they're gonna look like, the Cybermen.
Whoa!
It's okay.
I'm just gonna...
Honestly, I'm just gonna skip all this.
That's way too many people.
I'll just shoot the men.
Oh shit, I think I reload.
Oh!
Don't shoot and drive!
They always say don't drink and drive, but never don't shoot and drive!
Oh!
Alright.
I can outrun this.
But the loot... Oh, you're right.
Okay, you're right, guys.
You like, convinced me by saying loot.
Alright, I'm turning back.
You're right.
You guys always know.
You know I can't resist loot, guys.
You knew.
I might as well.
You!
Get over here.
Pew-pew-pew-pew-pew!
I'm gonna run you over.
Okay, we gotta get rid of him and him too.
Alright, nice!
That should be enough loot.
Dude.
No survivors.
The moment I hear loot, they're all dead.
It's time.
Oh my god!
These guys interrupted my plot!
My lore!
How dare they!
That's so fucked up.
We gotta get rid of these little guys though.
And... Pew-pew-pew-pew-pew-pew-pew-pew-pew-pew!
Okay.
They're almost dead.
Come on, dragons!
You guys can do better than that!
You used to one-shot people!
This is why you're not better dragons!
Okay.
Just like one tank that's living.
Alright, nice.
And...
Boom.
Oh!
Nice!
We leveled up.
We did it.
And then, bike time.
Yay!
We didn't see that.
Alright.
I wonder how fast we can go.
We can only go like 98?
Oh!
If we go straight...
If we go straight, it goes up, right?
What if I can upgrade?
Do I have enough now?
No, I just need one more.
What would you do if you ran into a tough enemy?
Let's see...
Well, I'd start by observing them carefully.
Knowing what they can do and what they're...
Oh, great.
We're at the southern tip.
There's no water anywhere.
Oh my god.
Maybe so.
Wait.
You think like now that I can play like Bandai games, should I play jump?
The best fighting game out there.
Yeah.
Do these old eyes deceive me?
It's a dam!
Jump Force.
You know, Jump Force.
The greatest...
The greatest shonen crossover of our time!
What do you mean?
We can have Naruto fight Goku!
There's the...
How do we get up there?
Oh, like this way?
Why is this this way?
All right.
And then we go this way.
Drift.
My god.
It takes so long.
The turn.
What the fuck?
How did they get over here?
Looks like there's something they really don't want us to see.
Yeah.
What is the twist?
There has to be a twist here.
Well, obviously there is a twist because they don't want us to see.
But what is it?
No.
No, there's like one!
Nice.
All right.
And then...
Absorb.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I have to walk now.
My legs!
I have to use my legs!
All right.
Time to use my legs.
Yeah, but there's a deep dark secret.
What could that be though?
Yeah, where do we go?
I'm here!
Let me drink some water.
Gotta stay hydrated.
Yeah, there it is.
What?
What the fuck?
I don't believe it.
They dammed up the whole river.
Wait.
So there's water this entire time?
Then the river didn't dry up on its own.
Wait.
Is it...
Are we like the only country with no water?
That's so fucked up!
Like the rest of the world is like...
The world's okay!
It's just this area!
I don't understand humans.
You'd go this far for me.
Bro!
That's why there's no planes!
So they can't fly over and see it!
It's really just this one area.
That stupid king is no more than a puppet dancing on Zale's strings.
So what should we do?
Just this place!
First, we destroy this dam.
It's just like Attack on Titan all over again.
There's a world beyond the Sand Land!
But you like...
Okay, like...
Okay, like there's like...
Come with us.
Uh...
Sand Land America is just out there and just being like, bro, what the fuck is going on over there?
The Sand Land America is just like...
We're just like...
Sand Land America is just outside with all the water looking at them and being like, what the fuck is happening?
Not all lands are sand?!
Wait, what's this?
Yeah, Water Land.
That's where the Sand Land stays in Sand Land.
Not a lot for words now, are you?
Just wait right there!
But Sand Land, not Sand World!
I promise you that I will make it quick!
This is bad.
We'll be picked off.
Hurry!
It said to the base.
I'm heading down!
Oh my god, I'm going down.
Gas, gas, gas, gas, gas.
Give me a sec.
Give me like three seconds to get my car out.
Here we go.
Okay.
I know what's going on behind me.
I hope my NPC friends are okay.
Those pesky rats refuse to die.
Hey!
Ready the insect man to battle!
Dr. Pussy?
Are you really sure about this?
We still haven't been able to achieve complete control over them.
Once they defeat the enemy, they may turn on nearby civilians.
Or for that matter, us.
Sorry, it's Pussy.
Sorry, it's French for...
What's that
round thing?
Can it be?
Get it right, Dookie.
It's French.
Oh my god, it hovered!
It hovered!
It is like the Frieza thing.
I could say the same to you.
Then again, you're too power hungry to let even death get in your way.
Why do you always have to go and cause such trouble, Shiva?
Why can't you leave things in peace?
Peace?
Don't make me laugh.
It's Make-A-Wish Frieza.
Is this tyranny what you call it?
I know everything, Sayu.
I hope you're prepared for the consequences.
You should be prepared for the consequences of crossing me!
You have no idea who you're dealing with!
Doctor Posey!
Now!
What's he gonna do now?
Oh, it's the Insegmen!
Frieza from Team U.
What did he look like?
What's that?
Okay, it's not their fault.
There's no showers in there.
Look how tiny the pods are.
It's not their fault.
Oh my god, this looks like the Cybermen.
Oh, never mind.
It does not look like the...
Never mind.
It was just the arms.
Growling.
It's just a bug.
One person?
Oh, demons!
How can the bugs kill demons?
Insect men actually looking like an insect?
That's crazy.
We have to sell at home.
I'm just running over with a fucking car.
A bug is still a bug.
I think you guys are forgetting an important fact.
I'm a fiend.
Hey, ugly.
If you wanna run now, I'll let you go.
Help.
Oh my god!
Guys, I don't think he liked that.
Damn.
What the fuck?
You're not so tough.
What?
I don't have the guts to be that big!
Hey, you're right!
Better be careful, Shiva!
There's one weakness.
A fucking punch!
We'll attack any and every living creature on sight!
Oh shit!
My bad.
What the fuck?
Put your shirt back on!
Oh, he never had a shirt.
God, he looks so much more naked without the cape.
I'm trying to wait for you guys!
Makes me... feel so weird.
It's just... it's just weird.
Is it
because he has no nipples?
Maybe that's why.
Appreciate it, old man.
But it's way too dangerous for you.
Got it?
Hide in the tank with feet.
Wee-oh!
Oh shit!
Critical!
Right off the bat?
Bro, how did you get a critical that fast?
Guys, I fucked up.
Guys,
I learned how to lock in.
It only took one.
It only took me like... a couple of playthroughs.
Jesus Christ!
Okay, we gotta go.
Get out of the way.
You almost got me, bro!
Oh shit!
He's like stomping on me like a bug!
He's treating me like the bug!
I like how it's just one of them that's taking fucking forever.
But there's like 20 pods behind us.
Like...
That's like the awkward part.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh, okay.
I was gonna stay outside.
Missed.
Like there's literally 20 different pods!
I did it.
Oh.
That other pods are eeky.
There's more.
Oh.
That's awkward.
Oh, no!
Oh my god!
It's not blood, it's just saliva.
Believe me, you haven't really seen the Prince yet.
What?
You demons have been athorne.
I like how the theme was like don't help him.
Is he gonna do a super scene?
I don't know, Steve.
I'm not getting convinced right now.
Oh!
Is this it?
He's actually go-hot.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Where the fuck was that?
Holy shit!
Now they're just level 10!
Bro, I don't even need to dodge anymore!
They're like two hit!
Holy shit!
Thousands and millions of dollars of research!
Dead by one fucking kid!
By one punch from a child!
Oh shit!
Oh no, getting their ass beat.
That's what.
Boom!
He's gotten super sated.
Dead by one angry little guy.
Bro, that's like millions of dollars of research right there.
That's like water money.
They lost all the water money.
His hat!
Oh, I just want to get out of here.
Can you understand me?
If you can, then we don't need to do this.
Goddammit!
If you can't kill Piazzalbab yourself, just self-destruct and take him with you!
Don't, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You take away the coco villain.
He's iron lung!
How would he breathe?
Guys, he'll be okay.
Nobody dies in this game.
He'll be okay.
That's like just like 80 feet.
It's not that bad.
How did he live?
That thing went...
What?
That should have hit his fucking body.
Sheba!
I yield!
I surrender!
Can't attack an enemy who's already surrendered!
I'm no threat!
Commander Zayu...
He's committed war crimes.
One more kill would mean nothing.
Just let me live!
To be fair, he's gonna die of old age like in one next week.
General Sheba.
Reporting for my new assignment.
I'm Alpha.
General!
We'll protect our home no matter what it takes!
I'm a father now.
Here's my son.
Isn't he cute?
You're back!
Oh, there's Sexy Terrier!
Oh.
That was Sexy Terrier.
For you I have no mercy.
Do it!
Pull the trigger!
Is she dead?
Did he do it?
Did he actually do it?
Bro...
He didn't do it.
What a fucking little bitch.
Did your diaper exceed its maximum limit?
Think about Super Chat.
You're as indescribable as you used to be, aren't you?
You should have took the shot!
Oh, he could jump that high?
Why do we need a fucking car to jump?
Oh my god, we did it.
We're gonna bring back WIDE IN THE SAND!
The rest of the world must have been like, what the fuck is going on?
Wait, wouldn't we like drown?
We should not be standing here.
I feel like the water is gonna fuck us up.
What?
Beelzebub never killed anyone.
Yeah.
It'll be okay, it's just the flesh rune.
Betty, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
How about you try firing at it with your tanks as well?
Worth a try.
But I'm not sure that's gonna cut it either.
Ha ha ha!
So even the great Shiva himself can't break down a wall this thick!
The Swimmers!
Those rats.
They must have followed us here.
What?
You wanna have another go?
W-w-wait a minute!
We just wanted to give you a chance to purchase this here beauty!
I don't buy the gun!
Damn.
Pretty serious ammunition for a bunch of two-bit crooks.
Bro, you wanna swim, don't you?
That's to blast your damn to bits!
I guarantee it!
How's 30 million zeny sound?
Bro, we're fucking broke.
I'm a child.
How would we have money?
You seem pretty friendly with the army.
Isn't that just a drop in the bucket to them?
Bro, they spent everything on those insect men and then I beat the shit out of them.
Unfortunately, I'm about to be canned for betraying my oath of duty.
I'm in no position to spare so much as 3000 zeny, let alone 30 million.
What?
Dang!
There goes my payday!
But, papa, you said you'd part with those shells for free!
Idiot!
Shut your trap!
Fine.
Let's just say you guys owe me one.
Prince, that ammunition is precious.
Do not miss.
Wait.
Do I have to get off?
I can't get off?
What if I miss?
I'm not gonna miss.
Okay.
It's fine.
I can have one.
There's eight bullets, guys!
If I miss all eight, then that's something.
Oh my god.
I should have seen.
I wouldn't know what it would have been like if I missed all eight.
We should have not stood... Why are we like this close to the dam?
Hehe.
Shouldn't we have done this before?
This one country just had no water.
Everybody else is just like, what the fuck is going on in there?
We could have said this before we shot the dam!
Damn!
Guys, we found fruit the moment.
Yay!
No food in my ass, I know, right?
Wait,
the king is gonna get away with it!
How about this?
Why don't you share half of your own personal fortune with both the citizens of this country and the few remaining Pichi?
Huh?
If rumors got out about you being complicit in Zeyu's scheme to cause and profit off the water shortage, that might sully your reputation.
I would suggest making a serious effort to recapture the hearts of the people unless you want me...
...to give you an unfortunate slip of the tongue.
He's gonna blackmail him.
That would be in the best interest of the people.
I would suggest that you take the best interest of keeping your reign from coming to a sudden end.
Uh...
Yes, of course!
Get rid of the monarchy!
Perhaps I will do just that!
Bravo, sire.
I would expect nothing less from our esteemed and honorable king of Sandland.
Because military rule is also... is definitely a better alternative.
Now that was something!
I can rest easy knowing that.
The military will be in your hands instead of Zeyu's.
Me, commander?
Don't be absurd.
I intend to retire from the army.
Is he gonna retire?
With what money?
You literally have like not... he just told us you don't have money anymore.
You're just another villain.
You should be the next supreme commander.
You're joking.
I'd never join the army again.
You're the only choice for supreme commander.
Go make a real king out of our foolish monarch.
And protect the peace, okay?
Hm.
Now...
Shall we go home?
We'll have them lend us the tank for a little bit longer.
Yeah!
Free tank!
So... Zeyu is no more?
Wait, that's not the end?
Who the fuck are these people?
Dispatch our troops at once.
Remember, secrecy is imperative.
That's chapter 14 out of 30!
Guys, it's not over!
Hahaha!
What the fuck is this little shithead?
I already don't like him.
Oh yeah, this is like the country outside of Sandland.
Who's like, what the fuck is going on there with no water?
Like...
Is it the other way around?
I need to know its map.
What above?
This is the map!
It's the map!
That's the map!
We're in the wrong place.
We don't have a map yet!
We don't have a map.
Alright, alright.
Okay.
Apparently, this is not the end guys.
This is only chapter 14.
Now we have a whole other country to conquer.
Wait, then this is not Sand Land anymore.
It's like just land.
Land Land.
Give the credit to the old man.
The rest of us were just along for the ride.
Of course.
Now then, I think it's time we paid our respects to the people who supported us along the way.
Can I finally use my chairs?
Off you go then.
I'll be in the garage.
Do I get a house?
Can I finally use my 50 chairs?
What the fuck is this kid?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I did.
Seeing all of you made me want to explore the world too.
That was reckless of you.
Explore the world.
That's still like the same area.
You just walked like a couple of miles and was like world explored.
I just knew I had to come visit.
I swear I'll make myself useful.
Won't you let me stay?
I mean, I don't really mind but what can you do exactly?
For starters, I can cook some laundry and clean up the house.
Whoa!
He's earning better than Anne.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
He's earning better.
I want that guy instead.
I wanna see the real dad too.
He's the peak.
Bro, he's even good at- We don't need Anne.
We don't need Anne.
I'll just have him do everything.
That's the peachy for you.
The town will grow now that the water's back.
They'll need- Better Anne.
Can I rename him?
I'll personally ask for your tour to let you stay here.
Thank you!
Better Anne.
Now you just need a place to stay.
That's your new name now.
What about here?
Are you sure?
Yeah.
It's too big for me by myself.
Plus, I wanna see your skills.
Replace Anne with Green Child.
By the way, I thought up a way to soup up the jump bot.
Interested?
Really?
Let's do it!
Wait, what is he gonna do to my jump bot?
Say no more.
Well done.
What did he do?
Now you can charge your jump to go even higher.
Oh, I can go higher!
Nice.
Whoa!
Awesome!
I could do this much in my sleep.
Gaining arrivals turned her into a show-off.
Way to go, Anne!
I need to follow your example.
Thank you, one and all.
I promise to pull my weight.
The jump bot is now more powerful.
You can jump even higher.
Make good use to explore new regions.
Oh, nice!
Where's Better Anne?
Alright.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
You can look at Better Anne.
Ginger!
Miracle!
Alan!
Duck!
And Cess!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, it's time to upgrade our vehicle.
Wait, can I just talk to Polack to upgrade my stuff?
Thank you, one and all!
No!
What if I want Better Anne to fix my vehicle?
I like it more!
It's not fair!
Alright, let's see.
We have the materials to upgrade this.
And then, might as well.
Alright, and then...
I don't have enough mats?
Oh, I still need the fucking...
Raptor Steel.
I always need the Raptor Steel.
Okay, does it make it faster?
Okay, actually, I don't need to upgrade my... I'm not gonna upgrade Scam.
I realize I don't need to upgrade Scam.
Alright, let's see.
162...
28... 28... I can upgrade this, actually.
No, I cannot.
I can upgrade this, though.
Okay, max.
Uhhh... what about...
Alright, nice.
It maxed out.
Okay, we don't need to upgrade Scam.
I'll never upgrade Scam.
I'll never upgrade you.
See you later!
Alright, here we go.
Okay, we gotta go to see the mayor!
Wait, that's not the mayor.
Oh, it's the mayor.
We gotta go... back up here?
Is the mayor up there?
He's so fast!
Yes, but my upgrades don't upgrade the speed, guys!
It doesn't upgrade the speed!
It's just attacking HP and we don't need to worry about that.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck is the mission?
Oh, it's here!
The Demon Village?
Oh, I have to go back home!
I have to go back home and be like, I'm back, guys!
I'm back!
I did it!
Welcome home, Prince!
Guys!
I got us water!
Yo!
You better not have been gaming while I was away!
Of course not!
We've been waiting patiently for your return this whole time!
Oh, yeah?
Upgrade Scam, you coward!
Bacon, thank you for the Akka Seek Fund!
Thank you!
It's time to get my game on!
If Scam had a hundred fans, I'm one of them!
If Scam has zero fans, it's because I'm dead!
Bacon's number...
Scam's number one fan!
Don't you have to report back to the King first?
Oh, yeah, right.
I should go back to the King first.
Go tell everyone back at Apato Village what happened, too.
Gotcha!
You think you'll drop by again?
Sure, once things settle down.
See you around, then!
Goodbye, Grandpa.
Okay, then.
Time to report back to Dad.
Dad!
I did it, Dad!
Papady!
He's the only remaining Dragon Ball Z character to live... to survive.
Big Dabura...
An hour and a half?!
He's the only one to have lived...
He outlived...
Uh...
He outlived all the other Dragon Ball Z characters.
He's a cool dad!
I get to play 30 minutes more!
Well, maybe I'm being too hasty.
Perhaps I should give these human games a try before I judge them.
Yay!
I got...
Game time!
Wait, he's back?
What the fuck?
Why is he back?
Wait, I did my job.
I did my job.
Oh my god!
Am I gonna get two PlayStations?
These supplies are for them.
Wanna come?
Yeah!
You bet!
Yeah, I do!
Aw, shucks.
I guess I'll tag along, too.
Now for Season 2.
Oh, that's right.
I've got a present for you.
For me?
Got this bot part as a peace offering from those little punks who wrecked my car.
Figured you'd like it.
Nice!
Thanks!
It's gonna be a long drive.
Let's make a pit stop at Spino.
Sounds good!
Oh.
Hey, old man.
What you been...
Oh, we're gonna make a pit stop?
Let me...
Oh my gosh, it's such a long drive.
Sorry, I skipped your lore.
We're going to need to do one thing ahead of us.
Make sure there's nothing left you need to do first.
Oh, shit!
That means like...
Uh...
This is like the last time we're going to be here?
Question mark?
Is that it?
Is that why you said that?
Damn.
Alright, I'm sorry.
I need to...
I do things for money.
You... You'd understand, right?
And you do things for money, too.
Alright, where is...
Where is Scam upgrade vehicle?
The one time I upgrade SCAM.
Oh my god, it's Crocs.
Bro, I have to use my Crocs, dear?
I skipped the important lore.
Guys, can you guys give me a quick wiki dump of what the lore was?
Ready to head out?
Yeah, I'm ready.
I think I did everything.
I got blue upgrades?
Not yet.
I got upgrades, apparently.
Not yet, guys.
Wait, can I- do I have it here?
I already got that.
Extra armor!
Wait, I'd rather have extra armor.
What the fuck?
What better dragoons?
You're already good.
You don't need anything, apparently.
Shotgun, grenade.
Okay, nice.
Quest in the mail?
No, that's just... that's just Miao Jin Bu.
I mean, I could talk to him.
I don't think I'm gonna be doing anything, but I could talk to him.
Oh, shit!
Raptor steel!
I need that!
Wait, he actually gives me stuff?
God, we don't need treasure.
I don't wanna fucking... I haven't found any ruins.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to go.
Yeah.
Yep!
All good!
Let's hit the road then.
Yeah!
Have you been back to see the Peachy at all since we busted the dam?
I've still got enough sex to have to venture south alone.
Alright, I'll give them lore before I fast travel.
You guys done?
Alright.
Where is it?
Yeah!
Fast travel!
We did it!
I wonder if the Peachy could make me a new game console if I asked.
You'd be lucky to get off with cleaning the whole village if King Lucifer found out about that.
Hello, Elder.
Oh, well.
What brings you here today?
It's not much, but we've brought some provisions for the village.
I did it!
Oh, that is extremely kind of you.
Of course!
I'm a kind person.
It's the least I could do to attempt to atone for my crimes.
If there's anything else you need, just ask.
I'll keep it in mind.
But let me give you something in return.
Whoa!
An exchange?
Maybe this would be of some use to you.
Watch this.
A gun?
What the fuck is this guy doing with a gun?
Yes, designed for self-defense.
We've covered up how-to.
Oh, I see.
A gun!
It's completely non-lethal.
Non-lethal?
However, it can temporarily stun enemies.
Bro, what am I gonna do with a non-lethal gun?
Really?
That does sound handy.
Bro.
Quite the peaceful solution to conflict, wouldn't you say?
Peaceful solution?
A gun?
It's okay.
It's non-lethal.
It's just a taser.
It's a good gun, guys.
The sheriff?
I'm sure you can make good use of it.
Definitely.
Thank you.
Well, we best be on our way.
Can't you stay a little longer?
We've much to catch up on.
Let me tell you about all the people that survived from your murders.
I suppose we don't have to leave right away.
You wanna hang out with all the people you fucking traumatized for the rest of their lives?
Yay!
We might as well go to the radio tower.
I realize we haven't done anything with the radio tower over there.
Alright, let's head to the radio tower.
And then we'll talk.
Hello, monkeys!
Oh, I can't punch when I'm running.
How do we get to the radio tower up top?
Oh my god.
Let me in!
Let me in.
Oh, okay.
I can just go in.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
I can just go in.
Nice.
Yeah, we can.
We have so much materials.
Alright.
And then we'll steal their loot.
Yay!
Alright, let's talk to this person.
I can?
What is it?
What the fuck is that?
Is it food?
I'm not scared of food, is that it?
You're worried too much.
Yeah, stop worrying.
I can't do anything.
Oh, it's like candy.
I can fly!
Whoa, what is this?
I'm floating!
Can I fly?
Cool!
That's so cool!
Right?
Yeah, you got me.
I thought it was candy.
Eat all of them!
If I eat all of them, I'll fly even higher!
It's called a floaty tablet.
You can have more if you want.
Wonka if he made Pez.
I can't see how these will be useful, but sure, why not.
Anyway, you Peachy are good with bots, right?
Can you fix a broken game console?
Yeah, even a baby could do that.
Really?
Can I bring it next time?
My console has been broken for ages.
No!
Not the console!
Sweet!
Marsha, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Fun fact, non-lethal guns are actually called less than lethal nowadays.
This thing is technically kill when used in the head and at point blank, you know what to do with it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Holy shit!
I mean, that's true.
Especially like, you can actually like...
lose an eye from it too and shit like that.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta...
I can fly now!
How do I eat it?
How do I eat my item?
Consumables.
What's it called?
What the fuck is it called?
The floaty tablet?
Can't even actually eat it!
It's just...
It's just aesthetics in my inventory.
Alright, nice.
I got standard spring and standard gear.
I can't believe it.
It's just there to look pretty.
It's just there to take up my inventory space.
At least there's no like, weight in this.
So I don't have to worry about being cumbered.
Where's the old man?
He left the village.
Saying he needed some time alone.
Oh no, he's emo!
Alright, let's go after him.
Alright.
Would you pass on a message to Rao for me?
Even now that this vast river has returned, there are some mistakes that can't be washed away.
But with the help of your new companions, your future can be bright and unblemished.
He's just suffering from PTSD at the moment.
Got it.
I'll let him know.
Alright.
I think I'm gonna call it here, guys.
Oh my god, I've been playing for four hours?
Okay, not gonna lie, the longer I play this game, I feel like the better it gets.
I'm gonna go save, but I'm not gonna show you guys the save because I don't know if it's gonna like, freak out again.
But I've been enjoying the lore of the story.
It's freaking out, by the way.
So, that's good that like, that's good that I tabbed it out for you guys.
But I've been playing for four hours.
I've been enjoying the game a lot so far.
I think I like, I've been... the story has been like, pretty interesting.
And like, apparently, where we stopped at when we defeated the commander is where the manga ended.
Manga and anime ended, right?
Or is the manga and anime still going?
I don't know, sure, not sure.
Is the anime still going?
But, um, so like, after that is when there's like, new... it's basically new stuff.
I haven't watched the anime before.
So like, I don't... I'm not sure yet.
Cause I wouldn't... I wouldn't have implied.
Um...
But the story so far, I really... I actually...
Uh... I actually really enjoyed the story so far.
And the fact that there's more to it.
It felt like it was the end.
And then they were like, by the way, this is only chapter 14 of 31.
I'm like, huh?
14 out of 31?
What do you mean 14 out of 31?
Uh...
Uh... but I... it's been very enjoyable so far.
It sucks that this game isn't more popular.
I thought this game would have been like, super popular.
Because it's the first game released post like, the passing of Toriyama.
Um... and the fact that like...
I think it's also because...
Okay, I think, not gonna lie.
I think the reason why this game was not... is not as popular.
Is because...
Because Stellar Blade released it.
At the same time.
So... and Stellar Blade had more...
Like, I guess like...
There's more... more things going around with Stellar Blade.
Than there was about...
Like in terms of like, there were a lot of things... news going around with Stellar Blade.
So...
Um...
Um... so...
It's unfortunate that...
Sandland released at the same time.
And...
Um...
And yeah, Stellar Blade got a lot of free publicity.
Um... but I honestly...
Really... I've been really enjoying...
I've been really enjoying...
Uh...
Um... Sandland so far.
Katz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The story is super cool.
Never heard of Sandland before.
But I really wanted to get into the manga and game show now.
Thanks for the stream on it so far.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it's actually...
I've actually been enjoying it a lot.
Like the story.
And I think it's also because it's like an action RPG.
I know I'm not doing a lot of the side quests because I've never been like...
A side quest person.
I'm really...
I'm really sorry.
I just like want to know more about the main story too.
I found the main story to be really interesting.
But I just want to progress the main story just to see what's going on.
Um...
And like...
Just want to see what's going to happen next.
Also the vehicles are really fun to use and stuff.
Um...
And...
Your town has no features because there's no side quest!
When can I use my chairs?
Is it because I didn't do the side quest?
So I can't use my chairs?
Is
that...
Um...
Anyway.
Okay.
So...
Um...
We are going...
Oh yeah.
It actually is.
Oh okay.
Yes.
100%.
Okay.
I haven't unlocked it yet because I haven't done any of the side quests.
Side quest locked.
No!
Anyway.
It is code time!
As I mentioned before.
Um...
It's two Steam codes.
Two PlayStation codes.
And two Xbox codes.
So I'm just going to...
What I'll be doing is I'm literally just going to...
I'm literally...
All I'm doing is just copy and pasting the code in the chat.
But I'll give you guys...
Um...
I'll give you guys a like warning before I do.
Like...
So...
I'll post the first code right...
I'll post the first code.
I'll do a countdown.
Are you guys ready?
Here's the countdown.
Five.
Four.
Three.
This is the Steam code by the way.
I'm doing the countdown again.
This is the Steam code.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Here's the first one.
Good luck.
You know, I'm going to do an interchange.
And then the next one will be like...
All right.
Good luck.
Anyone...
Is it activated now?
Has it been activated?
Yeah.
I'm going to do an interchange.
Good luck.
Free for all.
Who got it?
Someone got it?
Who was the lucky one?
Tell us.
Me smile.
All right.
Okay.
This one is PlayStation.
I pressed cancel by accident.
All right.
This one's the PlayStation code.
So people who are on the PlayStation, I hope you have a great day.
I'm going to boot it up.
No, it's two each.
But I'll...
I'm just going like down one by one.
So all right.
This is the PlayStation code.
Whoever has their PlayStation up.
All right, guys.
Boot your PlayStation.
Four or five.
It's like both.
I'm pretty sure.
I think it's like...
I'm honestly...
I think if you have a place...
I don't know.
Honestly, maybe it's PlayStation 4.
It just says PlayStation.
So boot up your PlayStations.
Are you guys ready?
Do you guys have your PlayStation ready, guys?
To activate this?
I'm going to boot it up.
Do you guys have it?
Do you guys have it ready?
Lag is crazy.
Look, the moment you see the code, then you're fine.
Okay.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Boom.
There you go.
All right.
Get your Xbox ready.
Guys, Xbox is next.
Xbox is next.
Who has...
Okay.
The PlayStation is ready.
PlayStation people actually have to type this out.
So, like, they have to type this out.
Oh, by the way, the Xbox code is fucking long.
Oh, I see someone got it.
Draven, congratulations.
The ice dragon.
They got the sad land.
Congratulations.
Woo.
The fastest PlayStation typing.
I'm going to go to the next one.
Okay.
Xbox is next.
You guys got...
Okay.
The Xbox one is fucking long.
Doki running a code fight pit.
We who are about to die salute you, I guess.
AV, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Get your Xbox out, guys.
Power went out.
Got your Xbox out, guys.
All three of you.
I bet you guys can get it.
Okay.
Oh, you claimed the PlayStation code on the website?
Guys, okay, I didn't know that.
I thought you had to type this out.
I don't know about Xbox.
Can you guys claim it on the website as well?
All right.
Are you guys ready?
Log into Microsoft store on your PC.
Oh, shit.
The strats.
The strats, guys.
That's cheating.
We have to go buy an Xbox, please.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
I'm going to do a countdown.
Five, six, seven, eight.
Four, three, two, one.
Boom.
And then a surprise twist.
I'm not going to go back to the PC yet.
The last PC Steam code will be the last one I'm giving out.
The next one is PlayStation.
I'm giving out another PlayStation.
I told you it's lag.
I was like, get ready.
It's pretty fucking lag.
I don't know.
I just got the code.
I'm not supposed to know.
Countdown is useless when there's 30 seconds of lag.
I pressed redeem without confirming.
Did anyone get it?
Damn.
That's cheating.
What do you mean that's cheating?
I don't...
Okay.
I'll do it in 10 seconds.
So, when I hit five, six, seven, eight.
5, you know it's ready.
Who's got it?
Okay.
All right, guys.
All right.
This is a PlayStation code.
I'll give a 10 second countdown.
So when I hit 5, you'll know when this look.
Okay.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
PlayStation.
This is the PlayStation.
And then we're going to go with Xbox next.
I like how someone's like type it you coward.
Oh my God.
I really like the person is like stop.
Don't you dare copy and paste it.
I got a creeper.
Congratulations creeper.
Congratulations on getting the PlayStation code.
Congrats.
All right.
Last one guys.
Last like not last one.
Sorry second last one because we set up one more steam code.
All right Xbox time the really long one Xbox time get ready.
Make look at look at the chat five seconds when I'm going to do with the 10 second countdown.
All right, just let the fast the 10 second delay or five second delay.
All right, 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bam.
Hey.
I have an Xbox.
I just don't feel like going to my basement.
He's just here for the ride.
It's rigged.
All right, there's the long code.
Good luck.
Good luck everybody.
And finally the steam players.
People on Steam already redeemed.
Holy shit that got fast.
Oh my God.
Whoever got that was fucking fast.
Bone viewers have no chance.
Damn speedrunners chat kept moving up and stopped me from redeeming bro.
That's fucking evil.
That's actually evil.
Like spam the chat.
They're quick so they can't get it.
All right.
Finally the steam code the steam code everybody.
Oh, Azi congrats Azi.
Congrats on getting it.
All right.
Here you go.
The last giveaway code of Sandland for everybody.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
There you go.
This one's going to be like going so fucking fast.
Good luck to the PC people.
Last code.
The last one.
Yeah, the copy and paste.
I just got here.
How is everyone?
Dragon thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're doing great.
We just played four hours of Sandland and had a great time.
Who got it?
I hit cancel bro.
Rest in peace.
Bro.
Stop typing.
I can't copy the code.
Bro.
Those poor people.
Stop typing.
I copied your name.
GG's.
I don't know who got it.
Then who got the the steam one?
I'm on a day.
I think I got it.
You got it.
Chubies.
Congratulations.
Chaz.
I thought I speed by copy your name with the code.
It choked.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Everybody who got the code who got the six copies of Sandland again.
A huge shout out to Bandai for giving me a giving me free copies to give away to the dragon.
They didn't have to do that, but they did and I really appreciate it appreciate them in the support.
Like I said before in the beginning, I never really had chance to really play Bandai games there ever at one point.
I really want to play Digimon.
But because like perms issue like we couldn't and then the fact that like not guy was like super supportive Band America was super supportive me like playing Bandai games in the future as well.
I really really do appreciate it.
And the fact that they wanted to send me some like.
I'm going to call it here.
Today has been a really long stream.
And tomorrow we have two streams.
So I'm going to call it here, everybody.
Thank you everyone for coming.
I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
It was a nice, chill stream.
I know it's part two of an RPG.
I knew a lot of people were going to turn up for this one.
But I still wanted to keep going because I've been enjoying the story so far.
And I've actually been enjoying the experience of Sand Land.
But yeah, thank you everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!
Wait, oh wait, let me... then just to thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think Bandai should give one more code.
So I can...
So those of us that choked can get a second chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ninjutsu, you know you're going to choke again, Ninjutsu.
It's just going to get worse.
Anyway guys, bye everybody!
Bye!